WE WE DO HAVE A QUORUM HOWEVER
WOULD LIKE TO WAIT FOR AT LEAST.
ONE REPUBLICAN MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE TO SHOW UP AWAIT
ANOTHER.
LET'S ESTABLISH A QUORUM WHILE
WE STILL CAN.
JONES SAWYER.
HERE.
LACKEY.
CARILLO.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK HERE.
SANTIAGO.
BOB SO I TOLD
POUND THE GAVEL.
NOW OUR OFFICIAL.
.
AND SINCE WE'RE WERE OFFICIAL.
LET ME AT LEAST GO OVER SOME OF.
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS.
OFF CALENDAR TODAY.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN.
CHIU PULLED BY COMMITTEE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB ONE SEVEN
SEVEN SEVEN. MERIT SUIT G. POLL
BY COMMITTEE.
BABY OF SEVENTEEN EIGHTY THREE
GALLAGHER POLL BY COMMITTEE.
IN ADDITION SINCE WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM.
LET'S GO TO THE.
THE WOMAN LOOKED AT LEAST READ
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
ITEM THE CONSENT CALENDAR THE
PROPOSED CONSENT CALENDAR IS AN
ITEM NUMBER TEN. EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT SALAS PEACE
OFFICERS BASIC TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN.
THIRTY FOUR JONES SAWYER
DEPENDENT PERSONS DEFINITION.
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN AB NINETEEN
FORTY ONE JONES SAWYER
MISDEMEANORS.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY EIGHT JONES
SAWYER INTERCEPTION OF
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS.
JONES SAWYER MUST KNOW SOMEBODY.
AND ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE HATE
CRIMES.
TING LAW FORTUNATE POLICIES.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
CALL THE ROLL.
JONES SAWYER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE LACKEY.
CARILLO GALILEO AYE GONZALEZ
LECTURE GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SEC CALORIES ADOPTED YOU KNOW
TENSE WE. WE ARE MOVING.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT MANY ITEMS
FROM WE SHOULD BE MOVING FAST
NOTE MISTER GRAYSON. I'LL THINK
WE'LL HAVE PROBLEMS WITH JOSEPH
WHAT YOU COME A PRESENT.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB NINETEEN
TWENTY.
TO GRAYSON IMPERSONATION SEARCH
AND RESCUE PERSONNEL. AND MISTER
GRAYSON SIGNED IN FIRST.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MOVED HIS CELL.
SIMPLY THIS BILL WOULD.
.
SIMPLY THIS BILL WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE ADDRESS.
THOSE THAT ARE TRULY.
CERTIFIED TRAINED AND.
ABLE TO DO CERTAIN AND RESCUE.
AS WELL AS.
IDENTIFY THOSE THAT ARE NOT.
AND.
THIS BILL FOR FOR REASONS OF
THIS AB NINETEEN TWENTY IS TO
REGULATE INDIVIDUALS OR GROUPS
PRESENTING THEMSELVES AS
PROFESSIONALS SEARCH AND RESCUE
PERSONNEL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I VOTE. THANK YOU WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
WHAT MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS?
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK AYE
MR GRACE AND FOR AUTHORING AB
NINETEEN TWENTY AND WE ALSO
WANNA THANK THAT COMMITTEE STAFF
AND ON MEMBERS ASK. STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION AND
CAL O. YES.
TO ADOPT SOME AMENDMENTS AND I
THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
HAS ACCEPTED DOES COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AND.
AT THE HE WILL A SAY SO IN HIS
ATOM AND HIS CLOSING.
ALSO I DO HAVE WITH ME AND
ASSISTANT CHIEF MARK BALDWIN
FROM CAL YES FOR ANY MEMBERS WHO
SHOULD HAVE ANY TECHNO QUESTIONS
OR NEED ANY EXAMPLES I HAVE.
TIMES WHERE I'M DOES WHO HAS AB
GROUP IMPERSONATED THEMSELVES IN
SEARCH AND RESCUE A PERSON OUR
CONDITIONS AND HAVE COME ON SITE
TO.
OFFER SERVICES WHEN IN FACT WE
HAVE NOT BEEN IS SLATED WITH ANY
ON LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY I'M
NOT WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IT THANK YOU FOR REMINDING
MISTER GRAYSON TO.
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS AND
CLOSE.
OTHER ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS.
GUARANTEED MY SUPPORT AND I
THINK THEY WERE VERY SENSIBLE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
WORKING THAT OUT.
WILL.
WILL GIVE MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES LITTLE TIME.
JUST IN CASE YOU HAD A QUESTION.
BOB ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB
NINETEEN TWENTY GRAYSON
IMPERSONATION.
OF SEARCH AND RESCUE.
PERSONNEL.
NEXT PAGE.
I MEAN.
NO.
OKAY OKAY AND YOU MAY CLOSE.
IN MY CLOSING UP I'D LIKE TO
STATE THAT I DO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS AND THANK THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE. AND A CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION FOR
WORKING TOGETHER.
THANK YOU MISTER GRAY CENTER AND
THE.
CHAIR RECOMMENDS AN AYE VOTE
MEANT VICTOR CONTROL.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY JONES SAWYER AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
KILEY.
QUIRK.
QUIRK I SANTIAGO.
THE MOTION WAS DO PASSES AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THE BILL
PASSES.
PASSAGE GRADUATION PICTURE.
AND.
MISTER VOEPEL.
YOU'RE NEXT.
YOU HEARING YOUR NECKS.
BLOSSOM CERVANTES OUTSIDE TO.
I WILL BE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. A
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO FIREARMS
UNSAFE HANDGUNS
MAYBE GET.
YES SIR. UP THE ORIGINAL BILL
WAS AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE
WHICH.
.
INCLUDED MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
ENTITIES
OVER EIGHTEEN OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT ENTITIES AND WHAT
THIS. ORIGINAL BILL OF
ESSENTIALLY DID WAS ALLOW LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HAVE VARIOUS.
WEAPONS THAT. WERE EXEMPT FROM
CALIFORNIA LAW FOR UNSAFE
HANDGUNS AS LONG AS THEY WERE
TRAINED AND HANDLED PROPERLY.
ONE OF THE ENTITIES THAT WAS
LEFT OUT OF THE EIGHTEEN OTHER
LAWN FIRST FORSMAN ENTITIES WAS.
THE HARBOR PLEASE FOR SAN DIEGO
AND LOS ANGELES
I RECEIVED A REQUEST FOR NO HAN
SAN DIEGO HARBOR PLEASE.
TO INCLUDE THEM UNDER AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO WHICH IS A
MINOR TECHNICAL CORRECTION. TO
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE.
THANK YOU ORDER ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
A WHIP.
A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
WHO?
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRATYLUS UNHAPPY
FIREARMS POLICY COALITION.
WE HAVE A NUMBER.
BUDGET. THE FIRST OF WHICH IS
THIS THE IDEA THAT FIREARMS THAT
ARE SAFE IN INCOME.
THE REST OF THE.
ARE NOT AVAILABLE TO.
EVERY DAY SERVICE.
I AND THEN WE CREATED.
ESPECIALLY BRANCHES OR.
OVER FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT.
ONCE AGAIN. THESE ARE FIREARMS
THAT HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED
UNSAFE.
WE WOULD NEVER ALLOW LONG.
THE RIGHT IN A CAR THAT HAS BEEN
DEEMED UNSAFE.
WE WOULD NEVER ALLOW THEM TO SIT
AT A DESK THAT HAS BEEN DEEMED
UNSAFE.
WE WOULD NEVER LET ME DO
ANYTHING OR USE ANY EQUIPMENT
THAT HAS BEEN DEEMED UNSAFE BY
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YET THAT
IS IN FACT EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE. THEN
WITH AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE WE
CREATED A WE CREATED A SECOND
TIER OF LAW ENFORCEMENT WHICH
BASICALLY SAID ONCE YOU HAVE THE
FIREARM.
YOU CAN NEVER SELL IT OR GET
RID OF IT OR TRANSFERRED UNLESS
YOU DO IT TO ANOTHER TIER TO
OFFICER NOW HERE'S THE PROBLEM
THAT THAT IS CREATED. IS RIGHT
NOW YOU HAVE.
FF BELLS OR OR PEOPLE WHO MOVED
HANDLE THESE UP A PRIVATE PARTY
TRANSFERS. WHO HAVE ABSOLUTELY
NO IDEA WHERE THE TIER TWO
OFFICER OR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER WHEN THEY COME IN? THEY
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THEY OBTAIN
THE FIRE HOW THEY OBTAIN THE
FIREARM IF THEY GOT IT USING
THEIR TWO YEAR TO EXEMPTION.
WELL THEN THEY CAN'T PRIVATE
PARTY TRANSFER TO ANYONE EXCEPT
ANOTHER TIER TO OFFICER.
BUT IF THEY GOT IT AS A PRIVATE
CITIZEN PURCHASED IT FROM
SOMEONE ELSE.
AS A PRIVATE PARTY TRANSFER
WITHIN THE COULD TRANSFER TO
ANYBODY.
SO DID THE THE CONCERN THAT
YOU'VE CREATED HERE IS FIREARMS
RETAILERS HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IDEA WHETHER OR NOT THE FIREARM
THAT THEY ARE TRANSFERRING IS
BEING TRANSFERRED LEGALLY. THE
OTHER ISSUE IS IS THAT IN TERMS
OF DETERMINING WELL IS THIS A
VALID OFFICERS DISAPPEAR TO
OFFICE OR NOT YOU'VE ADDED
ANOTHER BADGE.
THAT NGUYEN LAUNCHED WITH THAT
WHEN WHEN THE PERSON COMES IN
THE SHOW THEIR BAD TO SAY I AM
ABLE TO NOW TRAINS FOR THE
SPIRAL. THEY HAVE ABSOLUTELY NO
IDEA WHETHER OR NOT THERE
TRANSIT THEIR THEIR LEGALLY
TRANSFERRING A FIREARM BECAUSE
THEY DON'T KNOW WHERE THE
OUR ISSUE IS THAT NUMBER ONE WE
SHOULD BE CREATING A DIFFERENT
TIERS OF WHEN IT COMES TO WASTE
A CONSTITUTIONAL ENUMERATED
CIVIL RIGHTS AND THEN WHEN WE DO
SO. BECAUSE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
DOES WILL CALIFORNIA DOES WE
OUGHT NOT BE PUTTING FIREARMS
RETAILERS AT RISK SIMPLY FOR
TRYING TO EXECUTE THEIR
MINISTERIAL DUTIES IN IN. THE
END THE TRANSFER FIREARMS WE
BELIEVE THAT BY ADDING ONE MORE
GROUP OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OUT WE
ARE FURTHER COMPLICATING THE
ISSUE IS FOR THESE REASONS. THAT
WE OPPOSE THIS MEASURE AND I'VE
ALSO.
WANTED TO MAKE SURE TO NOTE
THAT THE.
GUN OWNERS OF CALIFORNIA HAVE
ASKED US TO EXPRESS THEIR
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YES.
LACKEY.
YEAH DOT SPECIFICALLY UNDER THIS
DEFINITION DO WE KNOW THAT.
WHICH GUNS A HARBOR POLICE ARE
TRYING TO ACQUIRE.
IN A TOTALLY I UNDERSTAND
THEY'RE INTERESTED IN SOME OF
THE NEWER GLOCKS I BELIEVE THE
GLOCK FIVE O'CLOCK SIX AND THEN
ONCE THEY RETIRE OR NEED TO.
UPGRADE AGAIN BECAUSE THE
TECHNOLOGY IS CONSTANTLY
CHANGING. THEN THEY WANT TO BE
ABLE TO SELL.
WHEN I THINK IT.
ANY OTHER QUESTION.
OKAY I'M.
SO THERE'D BE THAT THE CHAIRS
RECOMMENDING AND I.
AND AND.
BASIC BECAUSE.
THE D. INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
HANDLING. HAVE A HIGHER.
PROFICIENCY
THE DELIBERATE FIREARMS.
SHE LACKEY PROBABLY CAN ATTEST
TO THE TYPE OF TRAINING EVEN THE
HARBOR POLICE AND POOR POLICE
WHO. I ACTUALLY KNOW SEVERAL
OFFICERS IN LA PORT.
THEIR THEIR THEIR SKILLED WITH
BEING ABLE TO HANDLE FIREARMS
AND AS OFFICERS I WOULD.
I BELIEVE IT.
SINCE THEY ALSO ARE CHARGED WITH
ARM ENSURING THAT THE WRONG
WRONGFUL FARMS DON'T GET INTO
INTEROPERATION THEY HAVE TO
ENFORCE THAT. I WOULD BELIEVE
THAT THEY WILL ALSO TAKE A
HIGHER.
SCRUTINY AS WITH THAT FIREARM
GOES FROM PLACE TO PLACE TO
PLACE AND SO.
IT'S OBVIOUS WAS AN OVERSIGHT
THAT WAS LEFT OUT THE HEART
POLICE IMPORT POLICE HOLDING
CHAIRS RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
LIVE RIGHT BESIDE ME EMOTION.
SECOND.
WE HAD A MOTION TO GET.
UP CULTURAL.
ON AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO. CARILLO AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ WHICH
I KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU ROCK THANK YOU.
NEXT WE HAVE MISS.
BOB HOPE WE HAVE.
THE PRICE OF RIOTOUS.
CERVANTES ANSWER UP A PUT
SABRINA CERVANTES TOGETHER IN
IRAQ CERVANTES.
SABRINA CERVANTES.
I'VE A. B..
GEN OUT TO.
TAKING.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO I CAN'T READ
YOU'RE HANDWRITING. AND.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY.
AND WHAT EVER ONE YOU WANTED TO
DO FIRST THREE AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SIX FIRST OR. A. B.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
BEGIN BY PRESENTING AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SIX THIS MORNING.
FIRST OFF I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND I WANT
TO THANK YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR ASSISTANCE ON THIS
BILL. THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILLS
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESS OF
PROSECUTING SERIAL FENCES OF
SEXUAL BATTERY AND STATUTORY
RAPE AND TO PROTECT AND SUPPORT
SURVIVORS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE
PROSECUTION OF CERTAIN CRIMES
CAN BE CONSOLIDATED INTO A
SINGLE TRIAL IF THE PERPETRATOR
COMMITTED THEM ACROSS MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS. THE LIST OF
ELIGIBLE CRIMES INCLUDE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND CHILD ABUSE
HOWEVER THIS LIST DOES NOT
INCLUDE SEXUAL BATTERY OR
STATUTORY RAPE.
THIS MEANS THAT A SURVIVOR WHO
ADORED ONE OF THESE OFFENSES MAY
BE FORCED TO TESTIFY A MULTIPLE
TRIALS AND FORCED TO RELIVE THIS
ORDEAL HERE SHE. EXPERIENCED
THIS COULD BE VERY TRAUMATIC FOR
VOTE OVER SURVIVORS ESPECIALLY
CHILDREN.
NOT ONLY THAT BUT UNDER CURRENT
LAW UNDER. ARE UNDER RESOURCE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IT WOULD BE
FORCED TO GO THROUGH SEVERAL
COSTLY AND TIME CONSULTANT RILES
WHICH DELAYED THE PROSECUTION
AND PUNISHMENT THESE
PERPETRATORS. AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SIX MOVE THE BILL SOLVE THIS
ISSUE BY ADDING SEXUAL BATTERING
STATUTORY RAPE TO LESTER CRIMES
HELLO JUBAL FOR CONSOLIDATION
INTO SINGLE TRIAL.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY ON AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX WITH ME TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS JUDY TASK
GROUP WHOSE HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN DIEGO. COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY SUMMER STOCKTON.
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN JONES
SAWYER AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
JUDY TASCHEN ARE FROM THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SAN DIEGO I WORK OUR SEX CRIMES
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING UNIT.
AND I'M JUST HERE TODAY TO
ADDRESS YOU ABOUT AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SIX IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
LEGISLATIVE FIX TO OUR. SEX
CRIMES JURISDICTIONAL JOINDER
STATUTE
AND WE'RE SIMPLY ASKING TO ADD
TO COME TO THIS THING CRIMINAL.
COME CODES THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY COVERED BY THE
OPTIONAL ON JOINDER. AND THIS IS
SIMPLY BE STATUTORY RAPE CHARGE
AS WELL AS FELONY SEXUAL BATTERY
AND I HAVE PERSONALLY SEEN THE
TRAUMA THAT THESE VICTIMS
EXPERIENCE WHEN THEY GO THROUGH
THESE CRIMES. AND THEN HAVE TO
TESTIFY IN COURT ABOUT THEM AND
ALL WE'RE DOING IS GIVING THE
OPTION OF INCLUDING THESE
VICTIMS. IN THE OPTION OF
JOINING THEIR CASES AND JOINING
THEIR CHARGES WHEN THE
PERPETRATOR COMMITS THESE CRIMES
ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL LINES
BECAUSE AS WE KNOW SEXUAL
PERPETRATORS DON'T JUST COMMIT
THEIR CRIMES AGAINST ONE VICTIM.
OR IN THE SAME JURISDICTION THEY
OFTEN CROSS JURISDICTIONAL
COUNTIES.
AND HAVE MULTIPLE VICTIMS AND
SO THIS JUST GIVES THE OPTION OF
ADDING THOSE CHARGES TO GATHER
AND JOINING THEM IN THE SAME
JURISDICTION.
IF BOTH JURISDICTIONS AGREE.
AND THEN THE JUDGE HAS TO AGREE
TO SO YOU STILL GO THROUGH A
HEARING WHERE THE JUDGE HAS TO
APPROVE IT TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT'S FAIR TO ALL PARTIES. AND
THAT THERE'S NO I'M IN THERE IS
NO UNDUE PREJUDICE TO ANY PARTY
SO THAT'S IT'S A VERY SIMPLE I'M
ADDITION JUST TO INCLUDE THESE
OTHER VICTIMS TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE PROTECTED. FROM HAVING
TO TESTIFY MULTIPLE TIMES AND TO
ENCOURAGE JUDICIAL EFFICIENCY
AND TRYING THESE ALL AT ONCE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SHAWN HOFFMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
RANCHERO WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MORNING DAWN KEPT HIM ACU
CAPTAIN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
CRIME VICTIMS UNITED OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TWENTY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
COURSE ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
AND ARE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR STATEMENT.
MISTER QUIRK YEAH AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR TAKING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ARE I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT.
OKAY. ANYMORE. I'D A CHAIR ALSO
THANKS YOU I THINK IT.
IT ENSURES THAT.
THERE WON'T BE ANY PROBLEMS IN
THE FUTURE AND I. CHAIRS
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THAT YOU TOOK
TOOK THE AMENDMENT I WOULD HAVE
TO CHERISH RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
ON.
MISTER QUIRK MOVE TO BILL. CHECK
IT.
ON AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO DO PASS AS AMENDED
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY I CARILLO. CARILLO I
CONSULT IS FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THE BILL PASSES.
NOW YOUR SECOND BILL.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO TODAY IN
LATE JANUARY OF THIS YEAR A
REGIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCE BASE OUT OF LOS ANGELES
ARRESTED MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SUSPECTS IN A
STING OPERATION. AS PART OF THE
OPERATION LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS SET UP A DECOY ACCOUNT
ON FACEBOOK AND OTHER ONLINE
PLATFORMS WERE TAKEN ABACK BY
THE AMOUNT OF TRAFFIC. THESE
ACCOUNTS GENERATED AND IN AUGUST
OF LAST YEAR AN ALERT AND.
AMERICAN AIRLINES EMPLOYEE AT
THE SACRAMENTO INTERNATIONAL
AIRPORT NOTICE CHIU TEENAGE
GIRLS WITHOUT ID'S WERE TRYING
TO BOARD A FLIGHT TO NEW YORK
WITH NO RETURN FLIGHT. A BUT
THE TEAMS WERE TOLD THEY WERE
GOING TO BE PAID FOR MODELING
AND BE MUSIC VIDEOS BY MAN THEY
MET THEIR INSTAGRAM. THE
SPECIFIC INCIDENCES POINT TO THE
ALARMING TREND IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS UP BY USING THE
INTERNET AND SOCIAL MEDIA BY
WHICH A POPULAR SITES SUCH AS
FACEBOOK INSTAGRAM TO LOWER
POTENTIAL VICTIMS TO THEM. AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO MAKE IT A
FELONY TO CONTACT A MINOR WITH
THE INTENT TO ENGAGE IN HUMAN
TRAFFICKING THIS BILL WILL HELP
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMBAT THE
GROWING USE OF THE INTERNET BY
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS. AND PROVIDE A
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE THAT IS THAT
THE SOLUTION TO CALIFORNIA'S
HUMAN TRAFFICKING PROBLEM
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE WITH ME HERE
TO TESTIFY IS A SPONSOR OF THE
BILL. ASSISTANT ALAMEDA COUNTY
DESCRIPTOR ANY CHARMIN BAKU'S
AHEAD OF THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING
UNIT.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
MY NAME CHARMAINE BACH.
I'VE BEEN WITH THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DE IS OFFICE FOR ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS AND HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN COMBATING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
SINCE EARLY TWO THOUSAND.
I WOULD URGE A VOTE FOR THIS
BILL WHICH WOULD MAKE IT A CRIME
FOR PERSONS TO CONTACT OR
COMMUNICATE WITH THE MINOR WITH
INTENT TO COMMIT HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. AS YOU KNOW OUR
OFFICE INDIAN NANCY O'MALLEY HAS
BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT OF
DESPITE.
AND WE'VE LED THE NATIONAL
EFFORT TO EDUCATE BRING
AWARENESS THERE IS HOWEVER A GAP
WITH REGARD TO. CONTACTING
MINERS IN THE FOURTEEN TO
WHEN YOU ARE IN A AND A
PURCHASER SITUATION.
WITH THE INTENT TO TRAFFIC
THIS WOULD TARGET THAT EXACT
AREA WE'VE SEEN A GROWING USE OF
THE INTERNET NOW WITH THE INTENT
TO LURE CHILDREN. OF WHO
UNWITTINGLY FALL PREY.
INTO A DESTRUCTIVE AN
ASSAULTIVE SITUATION WHERE THIS
EXPLOITATION AND ABUSE CAN OCCUR
THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN OUR MOST PRECIOUS
RESOURCE.
I FROM BEING LURED.
BY PERPETRATORS FOR THEIR OWN
SEXUAL GRATIFICATION.
EXISTING LAW MAKES IT A CRIME
FOR PERSONAGES THIS WITH THE
INTENT TO COMMIT KIDNAPPED OR
SEXUAL ASSAULT WE ARE MERELY
ASKING THAT YOU PUT THE OBVIOUS
INTO THAT STATUTE AS WELL. AND
INCLUDE HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
I ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
BUT THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN RECURSOS ALONG
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
EITHER A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CATHY SURE.
KATHY SURE ON BEHALF OF THE ACLU
OF CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR
ADVOCACY AND POLICY.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE AB
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO BECAUSE IT
UNNECESSARILY CREATES A NEW
CRIME ADDRESSING BEHAVIOR THAT
IS ALREADY CRIMINAL UNDER
EXISTING LAW.
PENAL CODE SECTION TWO THIRTY
SIX POINT ONE PROVIDES THAT A
PERSON WHO CAUSES INDUCES OR
PERSUADES OR ATTEMPTS TO CAUSE
INDUCE OR PERSUADE A MINOR. TO
ENGAGE IN A COMMERCIAL SEX SEX
ACT WITH THE INTENT TO AFFECT A
VIOLATION OF SPECIFIED
PROVISIONS IS GUILTY OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
A DEFENDANT WHO COMMUNICATES
WITH A MINOR IN AN ATTEMPT TO
INDUCE THE MINOR TO ENGAGE IN A
COMMERCIAL SEX ACT IS GUILTY OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING UNDER THIS
PROVISION.
A DEFENDANT WHO TOOK A DIRECT
ACTION TOWARDS SUCH A
COMMUNICATION BUT FAILED TO
CARRY IT OUT. WOULD BE GUILTY OF
ATTEMPTED HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
WE OPPOSE AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BECAUSE IT WOULD UNNECESSARILY
FURTHER COMPLICATE CALIFORNIA'S
CRIMINAL LAWS AND DOES SO WITH
NO SHOWING THAT IT WILL IN ANY
WAY HELPED TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING WE
URGE YOU KNOW FOR.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE COURT
ARMED TO THE ALAMEDA ASSISTANT
DA IT SEEMS TO ME THE ACLU MADE
A CASE DOES THIS.
HOW DOES THIS CHANGE CURRENT LAW
WOULD INCREASE PENALTIES OR MAKE
IT EASIER TO CONVICT?
WHY IS IT THAT YOU WANT THIS
CHANGE?
BUT USE A MICROPHONE.
IT APPROACHES THE.
I WAS ONE OF THE CO AUTHORS
ACTUALLY OF PROP THIRTY FIVE AND
JOHN I CAN TELL YOU THAT THIS
LAW LOOKS AT IT FROM A DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVE THE PERSPECTIVE OF.
I'D SAY A PURCHASER AS WELL. IN
TERMS OF.
TARGETING THOSE CHILDREN AS.
.
SOMEWAY IS PURSUING.
SOMEBODY IN THAT IT WHO IS A
MINOR FOR THE PURPOSE OF
PURCHASING SACKS.
THAT IS NOT ADDRESSED IN TWO
THIRTY SIX POINT ONE WHICH HAS
THE INTENT OF SOMEONE BEING A
PEN.
AND THE TRAFFICKER.
WELL WOULDN'T THIS PERSON
ALREADY BE.
.
GEN IN JEOPARDY FOR HAVING SEX
WITH MINOR.
WELL YOU KNOW IT'S A IT'S A
PERSON WOULD BE IN JEOPARDY AS A
SIX FORTY SEVEN BE WHICH IS A
MISDEMEANOR.
IN IN OUR STATE AND SO THIS
LOOKS OUT IT AND PLACES IT INTO
THE CONTEXT IN WHICH IT IS IT IS
APPROPRIATELY PLACED.
WE HAVE FOR EXAMPLE STATUTORY
RAPE AND OTHER CRIMES
WE HAVE TWO EIGHTY EIGHT A
WITCHES WHEN YOU TOUCH SOMEBODY
UNDER THE AGE OF FOURTEEN WITH
THE LOOT INTENT. THOSE ARE ALL
IN THIS CATEGORY BUT IF YOU'RE
IN THE FOURTEEN TO SEVENTEEN
RANGE THAT'S NOT COVERED.
I JUST FIND IT DIFFICULT TO.
VOTE FOR BILLS THAT.
YOU NOW HE PENALTIES ON TOP OF
PENALTIES SO I'LL BE ABSTAINING
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE ANY MORE QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY WITH THAT.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE LET'S CLOSE THIS
LOOPHOLE IN PROTECT MINERS.
THE. AND I UNDERSTAND THE ACLU'S
POINT UNDERSTAND.
CORKS APPREHENSION ON THE CHAIR
IS GOING TO RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE
SO WE CAN MOVE THIS ALONG.
MCCALL ROLE.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TO THE MOTION
AS YOU PASSED THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER AYE AYE
JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY. LACKEY
AYE CARDIO. GALILEO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER. GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
KILEY. KILEY AYE QUIRK NOT
VOTING QUIRK NOT VOTING
SANTIAGO.
THE MEASURE PASSED.
CUNNINGHAM.
YOU HAVE TO MEASURES.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FIVE.
AND OUR ITEM NUMBER TWO AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN VERSUS.
I'LL TAKE WHICHEVER ONE THE
CHAIR LIKES BETTER FIRST WITH AT
ONE. WITH THAT BUT I THINK I
KNOW WHICH ONE THAT IS.
YEAH.
AB SEVEN THIRTY AT THE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FIVE.
.
IT'S NO SECRET. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THAT CALIFORNIA IS A.
A.
FIGHTING A BATTLE THAT IS REALLY
A WORLDWIDE BATTLE AGAINST HUMAN
TRAFFICKING.
WE HAVE UNFORTUNATELY THE
HIGHEST
RATE PER CAPITA OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING INCIDENTS REPORTED
SAYS MADE THE INDUSTRY'S A
HUNDRED AND.
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLAR WORLDWIDE INDUSTRY.
.
WHAT I'M ATTEMPTING DO IN THIS
BILL IN THE THE ONE THAT WILL
FOLLOW? IS.
STRENGTHEN OUR APPROACH TO HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IN PARTICULAR AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE.
SEEKS TO GIVE A TEN YEAR
RESTRAINING ORDER FOR VICTIMS OF
LABOR TRAFFICKING.
AND VICTIMS OF PANDERING THEIR
OVER AGE EIGHTEEN.
ALL RIGHT NOW UNDER CURRENT LAW
YOU CAN GET YEAR PROTECTIVE
ORDER IF.
TO TO SAFEGUARD THE VICTIM AYE
IT IF THE VICTIMS THE VICTIMS OF
SEX TRAFFICKING.
NOT THE CASE OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING.
THAT'S.
THE DIST THE DISPARITY THEIR
DOESN'T MAKE. A TON OF SENSE TO
ME I THINK YOU STILL HAVE.
A PSYCHOLOGICAL ELEMENT YOU SAW
PEOPLE THEY'RE BEING ABUSED
EXPLOITED FOR OTHER PEOPLE'S.
PERSONAL FINANCIAL GAIN.
TRAFFICKING IS TRAFFICKING IF
YOU WILL.
THAT TENURE PROTECTIVE ORDER IS
AN IMPORTANT PIECE TO GIVE THAT
VICTIM STABILITY. AND I CAN TELL
YOU HAVING.
BEEN A PROSECUTOR.
THE SHORT RESTRAINING ORDERS
ONE YEAR TO YEAR EVEN THREE
YEARS.
THERE'S A PSYCHOLOGY AT WORK
IT'S SIMILAR ALMOST ANALOGOUS TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PEOPLE.
AB AND REALLY BEEN.
ABUSED PSYCHOLOGICALLY
AND I CAN'T TELL YOU THE NUMBER
OF CASES I PROSECUTE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WERE.
YOU GIVE A SHORT RESTRAINING
ORDER AND AFTER YEAR.
THE VICTIMS COMING INTO COURT
ARE TALKING TO THE DA'S OFFICE
OR THE VICTIM ADVOCATE OFFICE
SAYING HEY I WANT THIS RESTRAINT
OR LIFTED.
BECAUSE THAT PERSON THAT'S ABUSE
THEM HAS
I'VE GOTTEN.
BACK IN TOUCH WITH THEM AND
CONVINCE THEM TO TRY TO GET THE
PROTECTION UNWOUND. THE TEN YEAR
ORDER AND AND
I GET A GIVES TIME FOR THAT
VICTIM. TO LAUNCH A NEW LIFE.
TO GET AWAY AND HAVE THE FULL
PROTECTION OF THE STATE.
TO GET AWAY FROM THE PERSON
THAT'S.
EXPLOITED THEM AND I THINK IT
BE A POSITIVE STEP FOR VICTIMS
OF TRAFFICKING.
NOT JUST IN.
WELL AND ALL ALL THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WITH ME IS MISS JUDY TAPPED
HER SAN DIEGO DE IS OFFICE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIRMAN
JONES SAWYER AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
JUDY CASHNER FROM THE SAN DIEGO
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE.
AND I THEM AGAIN THIS IS A VERY
A SIMPLE A SIMPLE FIX TO INCLUDE
GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN EXCLUDED
FROM THE OPTIONAL TENURE
RESTRAINING ORDER. AND THAT'S
ALL WE'RE SEEKING TO DO TODAY ON
IS TO INCLUDE THESE BASIC GROUPS
WHICH ARE THE ADULT VICTIMS OF
PIMPING PANDERING.
WHO ARE DESERVING AS OF MUCH
PROTECTION AS THE MINERS THAT
ARE BETTER PIMPIN PANDERED ON
THESE ADULT VICTIMS JUST BECAUSE
THEY TURN EIGHTEEN DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THEY'RE NOT WORTHY OF THAT
PROTECTION? AND IT IS OPTIONAL
IT'S DISCRETIONARY OF TO THE
JUDGE.
THEY NEED THE TIME TO GET AWAY
FROM THEIR PIMPS AND AS WE KNOW
FROM THESE CASES. THESE PANTS
EVEN IF THEY'RE SENT TO PRISON%
THEY OFTEN CONTINUE TO PIMP THEM
FROM PRISON OR WHEN THEY GET OUT
OF PRISON SO THAT TENURE ORDER
WILL HELP PROTECT THEM TO GIVE
THEM THAT SPACE TO BE ABLE TO
GET AWAY.
FROM THEIR ABUSER OR THEIR
PAMPER EITHER TRAFFICKER.
I AM ALSO INCLUDED IN THIS OR
THE LABOR TRAFFICKING VICTIMS
AND.
I NOTICED THERE WAS AN
OPPOSITION FILED REGARDING THOSE
VICTIMS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW WHY THEY'RE
UNDESERVING OF THIS PROTECTION
JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING ARE
TRAFFICKED FOR NON SEXUAL
PURPOSES THESE VICTIMS OF LABOR
TRAFFICKING WHO ARE DAY.
THEY'RE MOSTLY IMMIGRANTS THAT
ARE WORKING IN THE U. S. ON
TEMPORARY VISAS THEY WORK IN
AGRICULTURE HOSPITALITY
CONSTRUCTION RESTAURANTS.
THEY'VE EXPERIENCED SOME TYPE OF
FORCE FRAUD COERCION INCLUDING
DOCUMENT FRAUD WITHHOLDING OF
THEIR DOCUMENTS
DISTORTION ABUSE DISCRIMINATION
PSYCHOLOGICAL MANIPULATION. AND
VIOLENCE AND THREATS AGAINST
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
SO I'M NOT SURE WHY THEY
SHOULDN'T BE INCLUDED IN THIS AS
WELL JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
BEING TRAFFICKED ON FOR SEXUAL
PURPOSES.
SO THOSE ARE THESE THE SIMPLE ON
REQUESTS FOR INCLUDING JUST THE
SMALL GROUPS OF VICTIMS FOR THIS
OPTIONAL PROTECTIVE ORDER FOR UP
TO TEN YEARS.
THANK YOU OTHER ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING LUCIA MUCH OR ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
THINKING.
JOHN KEPT KEY ON BEHALF OF CRIME
VICTIMS UNITED OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
SHAWN HOP IN THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
JERRY MEMBERS JONATHON FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
RYAN SOME OF THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
MICHELLE THOMAS OUT ALAMEDA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING GANNAWAY.
CAPTURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA'S CENTER FOR ADVOCACY
AND POLICY WE RESPECTFULLY MUST
OPPOSE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE.
UNDER PENAL CODE SECTION ONE
THIRTY SIX POINT TO A CRIMINAL
COURT HAS THE POWER TO EXTEND
ITS JURISDICTION OVER A
DEFENDANT FOR A PERIOD THAT MAY
EXTEND. FAR LONGER THAN THE
DEFENDANT'S SENTENCE OR TERM OF
PROBATION BY IMPOSING AN ORDER
RESTRAINING THE DEFENDANT FROM
CONTACT WITH THE VICTIM FOR UP
TO TEN YEARS.
THESE ORDERS CAN HAVE A NEGATIVE
IMPACT ON A DEFENDANT'S ABILITY
TO RE INTEGRATE INTO THE
COMMUNITY. AS A DEFENDANT MAY
RISK VIOLATING THE ORDER
UNINTENTIONALLY IF HE RETURNS TO
THE VICINITY WHERE THE VICTIM
LIVES AND WHERE THE DEFENDANT'S
FAMILY AND FRIENDS MAY ALSO
LIVE.
DURING THE TIME THE ORDER
REMAINS IN EFFECT.
THE DEFENDANT FACES POTENTIAL
FURTHER PENALTIES INCLUDING TIME
IN JAIL FOR A VIOLATION OF THE
ORDER.
BECAUSE THIS POWER IS SO
EXPANSIVE
THE CLASS OF CASES IN WHICH IT
CAN BE EXERCISED IS NARROWLY
DEFINED INCLUDING ONLY SPECIFIED
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASES
SPECIFIED SEX CRIMES AND GANG
RELATED CRIMES.
THESE CRIMES INVOLVE EITHER A
PARTICULAR TYPE OF INTIMATE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
DEFENDANT AND THE VICTIM AS WITH
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CRIMES AND
BRIDGE REGISTRABLE SENSE OF SEX
OFFENSES.
OR IN THE CASE OF GANG RELATED
CRIMES.
SPECIFIC CONCERN ESTA
RETRIBUTION AGAINST SOMEONE WHO
TESTIFIES AGAINST THE DEFENDANT.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE
PROPOSES TO EXTEND THE
RESTRAINING ORDER POWER BEYOND
THESE NARROW CATEGORIES OF CASES
TO CASES INVOLVING HUMAN
TRAFFICKING FOR PURPOSES OF
LABOR OR SERVICES OR CAMPING OR
PANDERING OF ATTEMPTING OR
PANDERING OF AN ADULT.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS FOUND THAT
VICTIMS OF CERTAIN SEX CRIMES
AND OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE MAY
NEED PROTECTION.
BEYOND WHAT IS PROVIDED THROUGH
THE PROSECUTION AND SENTENCING
OF THAT.
BECAUSE OF THE NATURE OF THEIR
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE
DEFENDANT'S IN THOSE PARTICULAR
KINDS OF CASES.
IN THESE CASES AND ONLY IN THESE
CASES HAS THE RISKS TO
DEFENDANT'S BEEN CONVERT THEIR
RISK TO VICTIMS. BEEN CONSIDERED
SO GREAT AS TO WARRANT THE
EXTENSION OF THE COURT'S
JURISDICTION OVER DEFENDANT
POTENTIALLY FOR MANY YEARS AFTER
THE END OF THE SAN.
WITHOUT LEGISLATIVE RESTRAINT AS
TO THE TYPES OF CRIMES FOR WHICH
A RESTRAINING ORDER WITH.
MAY BE ISSUED SECTION ONE
THIRTY SIX POINT TWO WILL BECOME
AN AVENUE FOR LINK THE CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION OVER MORE AND MORE
DEFENDANTS.
SADLY THE END RESULT WILL BE
MORE OFFENDERS. FACING FURTHER
CRIMINAL PENALTIES FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THESE ORDERS EVEN
WHEN THERE HAS BEEN NO HARM TO
THE VICTIM.
WE ASK FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY.
THANK YOU. ARE TO ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY RTA QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
SO I'M JUST I'M.
CURIOUS.
ARE CONCERNED I GUESS.
.
I I'D HEARD EVERYTHING YOU SAID
BUT I'M STILL HAVING A HARD TIME
UNDERSTANDING. WHAT THE CONCERN?
FOR THE PERPETRATOR WHAT WHAT
HARM IS BEING DONE BY THE BY
SOMEBODY WHO LABOR TRAFFICKED
SOMEBODY.
WHAT WHAT IS YOUR CONCERN THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL WILL STILL BE
UNDER THE PURVIEW OF THE COURT?
YEAH.
SO THEY WILL REMAIN UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE COURT FOR UP
TO TEN YEARS UNDER ENSLAVING
SOMEBODY.
SO THEY'D ALREADY BEEN RECEIVED
A CENT.
WHICH MAY INCLUDE INCARCERATION
IT MAY INCLUDE DETERMINE.
PAROLE OR PROBATION. ON IT'S
NOT THAT THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
PUNISHED FOR THE CRIME WE THINK.
THAT.
FOR THAT FOR THAT TYPE OF CRIME
AS OPPOSED TO A SEX CRIME OR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CRIME.
WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THE NEED TO
GIVE THE COURT THIS ADDITIONAL
POWER FOR AN ADDITIONAL KIND OF
OF PUNISHMENT ENOUGH.
FOR THAT EXTENDED OF APPEARING.
OKAY THANK.
THANK YOU.
OPINION OF THE TO QUIRK.
YEAH I'M I AGREE WITH THE A. IN
THIS CASE.
ARM YOU KNOW STICK IT TIP
ACCORDING TO COMMITTEE OF
TYPICAL. PENALTY IS EIGHT YEARS
IN PRISON.
I THINK AT THAT POINT.
HOPEFULLY THE.
WE HAVE TO GIVE THIS PERSON A
CHANCE.
TO REDEEM THEIR LIVES
AND PREVENTING THEM FROM GOING
BACK TO PERHAPS WHERE THERE HOME
WAS PERHAPS WITH THEIR FAMILY
WAS TO ME MAKES NO SENSE.
AND IT IS MORE LIKELY TO CAUSE
RECIDIVISM THEM TO PREVENT CRIME
THEREFORE I WILL BE VOTING FOR
THIS THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER.
COMMENT.
MISTER CUNNINGHAM REMAINED CLOSE
IF I COULD CLOSE MISTER CHAIR
JUST ADDRESSING A FEW BRIEF
POINTS WERE BROUGHT UP IN THE
OPPOSITION THE FIRST.
ON THE ISSUE OF AN
UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATION OF.
PROTECTIVE ORDER THAT JURY
INSTRUCTION FOR THIS CRIME.
WHICH THIS DOES NOT ALTER IN
ANY WAY. A REQUIRES A WILLFUL
VIOLATION YOU CANNOT GET
PROSECUTED OR CHARGED WITH
VIOLATING.
WRITTEN OF PROTECTIVE ORDER FOR
JUST HAPPENING TO BE IN A MOVIE
THEATER WHERE THE PROTECTED
PARTIES IN THE MOVIE THEATER.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT THE PERSON
IS THERE AND COME WITHIN
TYPICALLY FIFTY OR A HUNDRED
YARDS OF THAT PERSON THAT
RESIDENTS THAT'S THAT'S THE WAY
THE LAW WORKS ON THE THING SIDE.
THIS DOESN'T.
CHANGE OUT I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD PREVENT SOMEBODY FROM
MOVING BACK MEAN WE DON'T WANT
PEOPLE TO REBUILD THEIR LIVES
BUT.
.
FOR THE CASE OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
LABOR TRAFFICKED WE ALSO NEED TO
GIVE THEM WHERE APPROPRIATE.
AS SHE POINTED OUT IT'S AN
OPTIONAL THING IT'S NOT
AUTOMATIC IN EVERY CASE BUT
WHERE THE JUDGE FINDS AN
APPROPRIATE.
FOR SOMEBODY WHO WAS ENSLAVED
AND BROUGHT SOMETIMES BROUGHT TO
THIS COUNTRY AGAINST THEIR WILL.
AND IS IS EXPLOITED THEY NEED
SOME TIME TO HEAL TO REBUILD
THEIR LIVES TO GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET AND TO KNOW. IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE THAT FOR TEN YEARS
THEY CANNOT BE CONTACTED BY THE
PERSON THAT EXPLOIT.
THAT'S ALWAYS SEEKING TO DO HERE
I THINK IT'S A GOOD STEP FORWARD
IN OUR COLLECTIVE FIGHT AGAINST
THIS EPIDEMIC THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU AND.
I DON'T KNOW SO DIFFICULT ONE.
AND.
WHAT GOT ME TO YES IS ONE
JUDGE'S DISCRETION DOES NOT AN
AUTOMATIC AT BECAUSE REALLY
IMPORTANT IS THAT IT IS EVEN
MORE IMPORTANT?
BUT FOR THE ACLU THEN. IMPROPER
USE THAT BECAUSE EACH CASE IS IS
DIFFERENT IS SEPARATE AND EACH
ONE WRITTEN REQUIRES DIFFERENT.
PUNISHMENT IN DIFFERENT.
TERMS OF HOW YOU YOU MET THAT
OUT BUT ALSO HOW YOU HELP
VICTIM.
AND ON THE VICTIM PART OUT I'M
DOING A LOT OF WORK RIGHT NOW
MORE TRAUMA INFORMED CARE.
AND TRAUMA DOESN'T LAST A WEEK
GOOD LAST YEAR BUT THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
I WILL SUBMIT TO YOU.
FOR SOME OF US IT LASTED
DECADES AND FOR SOME OF US
TRAUMAS GONE FROM GENERATION TO
GENERATION TO GENERATION.
ON AND SOLD IT IS IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T READ.
TRAUMATIZED VICTIMS LIKE LIKE I
GET THAT AND I I GUESS THE LAST
THING IS REALLY. AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT BOMB.
FROM THE PARTY OF THE OTHER SIDE
DAT. DAT.
IMMIGRANTS ARE BEING ABUSED IN
WAYS THAT ARM.
WE SHOULD KEEP THE FORMER
EMPLOYER OR WHOMEVER IS DOING TO
BE USER AWAY FROM THEM AND THAT
IS A REAL THING. AND I'M GLAD
THAT DHEA.
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE AISLE IS
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT IN IN IN THIS
BILL SO I'M RECOMMENDED AYE
VOTE.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER AYE
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE CARILLO. GODLY ALL
AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE KILEY. KILEY AYE
QUIRK NOT
QUIRK NOT VOTING SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSED.
IF YOU.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN SEEKS TO SIMPLIFY
WHAT IS
SORT OF AN OLD STATUTE THAT'S
BEEN RECOGNIZING CASE LAWS BEING
UNNECESSARILY COMPLICATED THE.
CURRENT DEFINITION AND PENAL
CODE TO SIXTY SIX AYE. OF
ESSENTIALLY THE CRIME OF
PANDERING.
HAS SIX SUBPARTS.
IT'S GOT A LOT OF PAIN
AMBIGUOUS LANGUAGE JUST GOT A
LOT A BROAD LANGUAGE IN
SUBSECTION SIX INCLUDES THE
WORD.
ATTEMPT AND THE MINUTE THAT YOU
PUT THE WORD ATTEMPT IN THE
STATUTE.
YOU'RE EXPANDING ITS ITS AMBIT.
TREMENDOUSLY SO WHAT WE'RE
SEEKING TO DO WITH THIS BILL IS.
.
COLLAPSE THE STATUE INTO A
SINGLE DEFINITION OF PANDERING
THAT.
.
ACCURATELY DESCRIBES USING THE
RIGHT VERBS ALL OF THE CONDUCT
THAT COMPRISES.
PANDERING IS SIMPLY RECRUIT
ENOUGH SOMEBODY INTO THE SEX
TRADE.
SO.
WITH THAT I WOULD.
OFFERS SHAUN HOPPING WITH THE
DA'S OFFICE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
AND TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ANYBODY
ELSE.
MR HOFFMAN MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHAUN OFTEN
WITH CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN.
AS HE SOME WOMEN SAID THE OBJECT
OF THE OF THE BILL IS REALLY TO
SIMPLIFY THE PANDERING STATUTE.
INTO ONE SUBPARAGRAPH THAT
BORROWS LANGUAGE FROM THE
EXISTING CASE LAW HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED YEARS OF CASE LAW ON
THIS STATUTE. TO ADOPT THE
MEANING THAT THE COURTS HAVE
PLACED ON A STATUTE. WITHOUT
MAKING SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES.
THEM THE ANALYSIS MENTIONS THE
EXISTENCE OF A JURY INSTRUCTION
IN CAL CRAM.
ELEVEN FIFTY ONE AS A REASON
WHY THE BILL MAY BE UNNECESSARY.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE USE NOTES OF
THAT SAME JURY INSTRUCTION THE.
DRAFTERS OF OF CAL CRAM NOTE
THAT THE STATUTORY UNDER THE
STATUTORY LANGUAGE PROCURE MAY
BE A DIFFICULT VERB FOR. JURORS
UNDERSTAND IN THE WAY THAT IT'S
BEEN INTERPRETED BY COURTS OVER
THE LAST CENTURY.
.
IN OF THEIR CONCERNS THAT THERE
ARE ELEMENTS.
POSSIBLY BEING DELETED I DON'T
THINK THAT'S THE INTENT AND I'M
SURE THAT THE THE AUTHOR AND
CERTAINLY.
THE FOLKS CAME UP THE LANGUAGE
WOULD BE.
WILLING TO TAKE COMMITMENTS TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE NOT LESSENING
THE BURDEN WE'RE NOT CHANGING
THE MEANING OF THE STATUTE WERE
STICKING TO THE CASE LAW BUT BUT
SIMPLIFYING WHAT'S ON THE BOOKS.
AS AS THAT HAS EVOLVED OVER THE
LAST HUNDRED YEARS SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR DON CAB
KIAM BEHALF OF CRIME VICTIMS
UNIT OF CALIFORNIANS.
YEAH.
GEN MEMBERS JONATHAN FELDMAN
CALIFORNIA POLICE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AS CHAIR RYAN CHAIRMAN THE
RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
NICK BROKE OUT A SECOND
ADVOCATES HERE ON.
YOU HAVE TO CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION.
I WILL SEE PDA REPPERT
APPRECIATES THE WANT TENSION
EFFORTS OF THE AUTHOR TO PROPER
VENN INDIVIDUALS FROM ENFORCING
THE PROSTITUTION.
REGRETFULLY MUST OPPOSE COUPLE
REASONS UNDERSCORING OUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS ONE.
NUMBER ONE CPA AGREES WITH THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WHEN IT
STATES OF THIS BILL AND I QUOTE
CARRIES A POTENTIAL FOR OVER
BREATH WHICH WOULD RESULT IN
CRIMINALIZING CONDUCT BEYOND
WHAT HAS BEEN.
TRADITIONALLY TREATED AS
PANDERING. AT IS AN EXAMPLE OF
THIS.
.
BY REMOVING THE REQUIREMENTS OF
FORCE OR THREATS IT WOULD BE
CONCEIVABLE THAT A CUSTOMER OR
JOHN COULD BE PROSECUTED FOR
PANDERING WHICH OF COURSE IS A
FELONY OFFENSE. SINCE THE
CUSTOMER WOULD BE ENCOURAGING
THE PROSTITUTE TO COMMIT A
SINGLE ACT
OF PROSTITUTION.
AS COMMITTEE ANNOUNCES STATES
THIS RACE IS A PROBLEM THAT
LOWER LEVEL CONDUCT COULD BE
PROSECUTED AND PUNISHED AND
HIGHER LEVEL THAN WAS INTENDED
BY THE STATUTE.
CLOSE QUOTE BRANDING THE AMBIT
OF OFFENDERS SUBJECT TO STATE
PRISON UNDERCUTS THE STATE'S
EFFORT TO COMPLY WITH A FEDERAL
COURT ORDER MANDATING THAT
CALIFORNIA MEET CERTAIN CAPS ON
ITS PRISON POPULATION.
A SECOND REASON UNDER SWING
OPPOSITION IS THIS.
THE PROPOSED DEFINITION OF
PANDERING UNDER AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN IS VAGUE AND
AMBIGUOUS.
I FOR EXAMPLE UNDER AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN A RUNWAY MINOR WHO
WAS LEFT AT HOME TO AVOID
ABUSIVE SITUATION.
I COULD SAY TO ASSEMBLY SITUATED
PEER CAUGHT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER
HUSTLING BECAUSE I'M MAKING GOOD
MONEY WAS QUOTE. AND
SUBSEQUENTLY PROSECUTE FOR
PAINTINGS A FELONY.
THE SAME HOLDS TRUE FOR VICTIMS
OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND A
VICTIM OF SEX TRAFFICKING.
THE REALITY IS THAT MANY WHO
ENGAGE IN SELLING SEXUAL
SERVICES OF SEPARATE THEIR HEART
RENDING PLATES MANY VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL TRAFFICKING OF SUFFERED.
AND SHOULD NOT BE FOR THE
VICTIMIZED BY BEEN CONVICTED OF
FELONY PANDERING. WE RECOGNIZE
THAT IT'S ALL IN THE PROCESS BUT
BE ASKING ABOUT IT THIS TIME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NATO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR ADVOCACY
IN POLICY AND AND ARM POLICY.
OUT WE APOLOGIZE FOR NOT HAVING
GOTTEN IN A LETTER ON THIS ONE
BUT WE ARE IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY CBT.
THANK YOU.
AND WITNESSES GETTING QUESTIONS.
GONZALEZ LECTER.
SO I'M MISTER CUNNINGHAM BECAME
CEO ON SCIENCE. AND IT'S HARD.
LIKE TO LOOK IN THE EYE.
SO.
THE OPPOSITION BROUGHT TWO
POINTS
THE FIRST OF WHICH I THINK IS
WRONG DAY HAD A BILL WANTS THAT.
THE COP VETOED THAT.
SAYS JOHN SHOULD BE HELD TO A
FELONY STANDARD I BELIEVE THAT'S
TRUE THE PEOPLE ACTUALLY.
PURCHASING SACKS WE NEED A.
ACTUALLY HOLD RESPONSIBLE
HOWEVER THE SECOND POINT IS ONE
THAT I THINK I'M. I'M MORE
SENSITIVE TAIL AND THAT'S WE'VE
DONE A LOT OF WORK TO ENSURE
WERE DEALING WITH.
.
VICTIMS OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING AS
VICTIMS AND SOMETIMES THAT
CAUSES THEM TO DO OTHER THINGS
THAT.
NORMALLY WE WOULDN'T WANT THEM
TO DO BUT THEY'RE UNDER A
CERTAIN SITUATION WHERE WHERE.
I'M A VICTIM OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING BASE OF THEIR SEX
TRAFFICKING ON ASCENT OUT TO TO
GO RECRUITING ENCOURAGE TOM.
MORE GIRLS INTO THIS I WOULDN'T
WANT THEM CAPTURED SO.
I'M I KNOW THAT THE CHAIR HAS A.
RECOMMENDED NO I'M VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE I'M VOTING YES OR
NO ON THIS BUT I WAS WONDERING.
IF THERE'S ANYWAY YOU CAN.
.
WE CAN'T HAVE I'M NOT
SUGGESTING.
ANY BUT IT'S EARLY IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BUT IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO WORK ON THAT
SECOND PIECE.
I'D BE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS IF IT WAS ONLY
AIMED AT EX IT IF THAT A FACT
WOULD ONLY BE THAT. YOU KNOW
JOHNSON PEOPLE PURCHASING SACKS
WHERE FALLING UNDER THE
PANDERING I'M FINE WITHOUT IT'S
A SECOND PIECE I'M REALLY
CONCERNED WITH AND THE REASON I
CAN'T VOTE FOR THIS TODAY.
RIGHT.
COULD TAKE A MOMENT TO ADDRESS
THE RUSSIAN.
AB.
YEAH SO ONE THING IN LOOKING AT
THE SIMPLIFIED DEFINITION WE'RE
TRYING TO.
AND WE REALLY ARE TRYING TO
SIMPLIFY AND NARROWED THE
STATUTE.
THAT'S THE INTENT I DON'T KNOW
THAT WERE QUITE THERE WITH THE
LANGUAGE WE HAVE THE WORD.
ENCOURAGES INCLUDED WHICH IS
PROBABLY.
GETTING TO THE.
THE THE ISSUE YOU HAVE WITH THAT
I MEAN THAT PROBABLY IS A LITTLE
BIT OF OVERBRETT THERE ARE
POTENTIALLY COULD BE.
USES SNARE SOMEBODY WHO'S A
VICTIM THEMSELVES.
SON I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK
ON.
NEARING THE STATUTE ELIMINATING
THAT TERM IS PROBABLY A GOOD
START.
.
I WOULD SAY THOUGH IT'S THE
STATUTE NOW. THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO CHANGE HAS.
SIX PRONGS.
THE SIXTH OF WHICH.
IS.
INCLUDES AN ATTEMPT TO PROCURE.
YEAH IF BE SUCCESSFUL USED
ASK SOMEBODY IF THEY'LL COME
WORK FOR YOU AN. IN THE SEX
TRADE. AND
HE.
THEY SAY NO BUT IF YOU CAUGHT
ON.
SOMEHOW THAT GETS RECORDED YOU
CAN BE CHARGED I MEAN.
IT IT'S VERY BROAD STATUE THAT
STANDS NOW I THINK WE'RE TRYING
TO ACTUALLY CAN. NARROW
SIGNIFICANTLY AND CLARIFY AND
THE PROSECUTORS NOW UNDER THE
STATUTE HAVE FULL DISCRETION TO
CHARGE.
UNDER A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
THEORIES
I MEAN THIS WOULD MAKE ONE THING
IF YOU CAN MEET IF YOU CAN PROVE
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT THEY
DID THIS THING. WHICH WERE YOU
KNOW DEFINING PANDERING
ESSENTIALLY THEN. THEN YOU
YOU'VE GOT A CASE AS A
PROSECUTOR RIGHT NOW THAT THIS
GIVES THEM A TON A THEORY
ELECTIONS
SO AT.
I I GUESS I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE THAT.
WILL.
THE PROPOSED NEW LANGUAGE OF THE
STATUTE IS IN ANY WAY
BROADENING.
THE CRIME I THINK IT'S ACTUALLY
NARROWING. BUT I'M HAPPY TO.
AS.
KINDA TOUGH ONE TODAY.
AND I'M HAPPY TO WORK ON
AMENDMENTS.
ANY OTHER. COMMENT.
WORK YEAH ARM.
I AM BASING MY JUDGMENT ON WHAT
THE ANALYSIS SAYS I THINK YOU
ARE BROADENING IT.
I DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT FELONY
FOR TALENTS IS THAT REALLY WHAT
YOUR INTENTION.
WELL THE THAT THAT'S ARE ON THE
BOOKS ALREADY BEEN.
I FELL ON THE FOR PANDERING.
ALRIGHT FOR PANDERING BUT.
THE ANALYSIS SEEMS TO SAY THAT.
JOHNS COULD ALSO BE.
UNDER THE WAY YOU'VE WRITTEN
THIS ALSO BE.
RESPONSIBLE FOR A FELONY WHICH.
I DON'T THINK MAKES
GOOD SENSE AND AGAIN WERE.
WHERE TRYING TO PUNISH OUR WAY
OUT OF SOMETHING AND I JUST
DON'T THINK THAT WORKS?
IS THAT NOT YOUR INTENT.
CAN MISTER HOFFMAN ADDRESS THAT.
NO THAT'S NOT MY INTENT.
ALRIGHT.
CHAIRPERSON ADDRESS THAT SURE.
DIDN'T THE CASE LAW ON WHICH
THE LANGUAGES BASED IS PRETTY
CLEAR THAT A PERSON CANNOT BE
CONVICTED OF PANDERING FOR. A
ENACT A SOLICITATION OKAY SO IF
IF.
THE INTERPRETATION OF THE WAY
THAT THIS IS DRAFTED SUGGEST
THAT MAYBE THE CASE THAT IS NOT
THE INTENT THE INTENSIVE TELLER
THIS TO THE CASE LAW WHICH IS
PRETTY CLEAR ON THAT POINT THAT
THAT IS.
NOT AN OUTCOME THAT WOULD BE
INTENDED.
BY THE AUTHOR WELL INTO LET'S
CLARIFIED I REALLY CAN'T VOTE
FOR THE BILL.
SHOW.
I'LL WANT TO HEAR WHAT THE CHAIR
HAS TO SAY.
THEY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
GO AFTER PEOPLE THAT ARE THAT
ARE RECRUITING PEOPLE INTO THE
INTO THE TRADE. ARRANGES CAUSES
ENCOURAGES INDUCES PERSUADE TO
PROCURE. ANOTHER PERSON TO BE A
PROSTITUTE.
AND.
.
NO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO.
THE BECAUSE THE SOLICITATION
ASPECTS NOT INCLUDED IN THIS.
CORRECTED THAT YOU'RE CLOSING
ILLEGAL NOW. THAT NICKLAS
VOTE BUT I I THOUGHT I WOULD
MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS I.
APPRECIATE THAT THE DIALOGUE
MORE THAN HAPPY TO WORK ON.
.
AND THEN IT'S THE.
GET OUT A SIMPLIFIED STATUTE
THAT'S MORE WORKABLE I THINK IN
THE COURTROOM AND.
.
I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION FOR OUR.
FOR HUMAN TRAFFICKING EFFORTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU AS
WELL I'M GOING TO ASK THE
COMMITTEE.
IS TO VOTE.
S. DOWN VOTE NO. AND I WANT TO
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION.
SO THAT WE HAVE TIME TO WORK ON
IT BREAK OUT AT THE SOURCE.
AND WHATEVER ELSE YOU NEED.
TAKE TO
I THINK YOU HERE'S A WILLINGNESS
ON AT LEAST.
TWO MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
THAT HAVE PROBLEMS WITH THE
WORDING I I I I PROBLEMS WITH
THE WORDING ALSO.
.
AT A TO POINT WHERE.
YOU KNOW UP WHICH CUNNINGHAM
YOUR YOUR FORMER PROSECUTOR YOU
COULD.
TALK ABOUT HOW PEOPLE THAT IN
THIS BUSINESS MAKE EXTRA MONEY
MONEY DRIVE NEW CARS GOT A NEW
HOUSE.
AND IF SOMEBODY GOES OUT.
AND DOES IT AND NEXT TO YOU
KNOW.
THEY SAY THAT MR CUNNINGHAM
ENCOURAGEMENT THAT'S HOW BROUGHT
I THINK THIS IS THAT.
SOMEBODY THEY COULD COME AFTER
YOU AND SO.
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO.
BELOW MORE SPECIFIC. AND IN
MAKING SURE THAT WE DON'T A
SNARE PEOPLE.
WHO SOME KNOW DISRESPECTED? THAT
A PROSECUTOR MAY HAVE.
MAY OVER PROSECUTE OR OURS IN
SNEER SOME PEOPLE THAT.
MAY NOT HAVE HAD THAT INTENTION
AND WHICH IS.
TALKING FACT AN OFF THE CUFF
SO IF WE.
IF WE COULD VOTE THIS DOWN NOW
AND THEN YOU WORK WITH.
MEMBER THIS COMMITTEE. AND THE
COMMITTEE STAFF BECAUSE I'M I'M
NOT CERTAIN IF WE HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY WORK WELL
WITH YOU ON THIS BILL RIGHT NOW.
AND SO OF.
I KNOW WE WERE ABLE TO COME UP
WITH A LOT OF OTHER
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AMENDMENTS
THAT GOT A LOT OF BILLS THROUGH
TODAY. AND.
.
UNTIL A AT I DON'T THINK
COLLEGES LAWSUIT WE JUST NEED TO
REGROUP AND COME BACK AGAIN.
SUBJECT RECOMMENDING A NO VOTE.
IF THERE MOTION.
ON AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN THE
MOTION IS TO PASTOR
APPROPRIATIONS JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER NO LACKEY LACKEY
AYE CARILLO.
PATIO NO CONSULTAS LECTURE.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER NOT VOTING
KILEY. KILEY AYE QUIRK.
NO PARK NO SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE FAILED.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION PLEASE.
GRANTED BY IN A GIVEN AYE
EURONYMOUS CONSENT.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
SO I'M I WILL HAVE. MISTER
LACKEY GO UP NEXT.
BECAUSE THEY'VE WAITED
PATIENTLY.
WHAT IF?
LARGER JUST STEPPED DOWN.
OH OKAY. SO WILL GO WITH.
MS GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
AND IT IS NOT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB NINETEEN NO THREE IS SIMPLE
IT CAME OUT OF.
A VERY.
.
SIMPLE SITUATION THAT HAPPENED
IN MY COMMUNITY. I'M DONE BY
BACK BILLS ARE GUN BUYBACK
PROGRAMS WE COULD TALK ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE EFFECTIVE
BUT THE PROCESS ARE THE REASON
THAT WE DO THEM IS BASICALLY. TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF GUNS OUT
THERE WHETHER IT'S GUNS IN
SOMEBODY'S HOUSE THAT THEY'RE
NOT USING WHETHER IT'S BROKEN
GUNS WHETHER IT'S LEGAL GUNS ON
THE STREET. IT IS A DON'T ASK
ANY QUESTIONS TURNING GUNS.
I'M IN MY DISTRICT.
WHILE THESE GUNS WERE BEING
TURNED AND THEY WERE GETTING
GIFT CARDS FOR A RETAILER'S.
SOMETIMES THAT SOLD GUNS AND
AMMUNITION AND IT'S JUST A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE THAT I
THINK IF OUR GOAL IS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF GUNS THROUGH GUN
BUY BACK PROGRAMS THAT WE DON'T
THEN. I TURN AROUND AND GIVE A
GIFT CARD TO A DEALER OF GUNS OR
AMMUNITION SO IT'S COMMON SENSE
TO PROTECT TAXPAYER DOLLARS AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITH ANY WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
HOW YOU DOING?
THE MAN WITH THE NEW BEARD.
I MEAN HERE.
HOW I WISH CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE CRAIG TO LOSE ON
BEHALF OF THE FIREARMS POLICY
COALITION? YOU OFTENTIMES WE SEE
THESE MEASURES.
INTRODUCED IN THERE CALLED
COMMON SENSE
AND THE THE FIREARM INTO SURE
FIREARMS
CULTURE THAT THEY UNDERSTAND
THESE BILLS HAVE LITTLE TO NO
IMPACT ACTUALLY SHOULD BE
DEEMED.
AS COMMON NONSENSE
A THIS PARTICULAR MEASURE ARISES
BECAUSE GIVE CARDS TO WALMART
WHICH BY THE WAY DOES NOT SELL
FIREARMS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ANOTHER DO SELL IN
SOME PLACES THEY DO SELL
AMMUNITION.
THE THE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
WITH THIS FIRST OF ALL IT'S JUST
THE THEY AND I THINK EVERYONE
CAN AGREE THERE'S QUESTIONS AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT. A GUN BUY
BACK PROGRAMS WORK WILL MAYBE
THERE ARE I I KNOW THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH INFORMATION AS IS
PROVIDED IN OUR LETTER THAT
DEMONSTRATES THEY ARE NOT IN
FACT EFFECTIVE.
BUT THE OTHER CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE WITH GUN BUY BACK PROGRAMS
IT IS LITERALLY A WAY FOR
CRIMINALS TO DISPOSE OF FIREARMS
THAT HAS BEEN USED IN THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME. WITH
ABSOLUTELY NO CONSEQUENCES AND
NO QUESTIONS ASKED.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE AT
THE VERY LEAST BE AMENDED TO
REQUIRE THE RECORDING OF
SIGNATURES OUR SIGNATURE OF
SERIAL NUMBERS AND INFORMATION
BALLISTICS INFORMATION ON THESE
FIREARMS TO DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT THEY ARE INVOLVED. THEY HAD
BEEN INVOLVED IN ANY CRIME BUT
WITH THAT ONCE AGAIN THE IDEA
PUTTING GOVERNMENT MONEY INTO
PUT INTO A PROGRAM. OF THAT IS
GOING THAT IS ALLOWS FOR.
WEAPONS THAT ARE USED IN THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME IS JUST.
LUDICROUS
ALL IN THE GUISE OF SAYING WELL
WE WANT TO.
WE DON'T WE WANT TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF GUNS AND WE DON'T WANT
TO PUT AN IMAGE OUT THERE THAT
WE SUPPORT.
FIREARMS WILL LET'S JUST BE
CLEAR OTHER THAN THOSE WHO SELL
THE FIREARMS THE NUMBER ONE
PROFITEER ARE THE NUMBER ONE
GROUP THAT RECEIVED THE MOST
RESOURCES FROM GUN SALES AND
AMMUNITION SALES. IS THE
GOVERNMENT THE NUMBER ONE
PURCHASER IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OF FIREARMS AND
AMMUNITION IS THE GOVERNMENT.
SO IT IF WE WANT TO.
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF THE AMOUNT
OF AMMUNITION THE AMOUNT OF
FIREARMS THAT ARE OUT THERE IF
WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO PROMOTE
FIREARMS THEN MAYBE IT OUGHT NOT
BE A BUSINESS THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
PROFIT FROM AND PARTICIPATE IN.
IS WITH THIS THAT WE ARE OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE UNLESS IT IS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR DELUDE.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
HEARING THE.
WITNESS TO QUELL THERE IS ONE
THING I HEARD WHICH IS SHOULD WE
BE. GETTING SERIAL NUMBERS WHEN
WE BUY BACK GUNS AND OTHERWISE
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE BEEN USED
IN A CRIME. I'M NOT QUITE SURE
THE EFFICACY OF THAT BUT.
YOU'RE NOT SURE EITHER OKAY LIKE
I WANTED TO BE CLEAR I I AM NOT
HERE I DID NOT CREATE THIS
PROGRAM I HAVE MIXED EMOTIONS
ABOUT THE GUN BUY BACK PROGRAM
BUT. HAVING SEEN THEM.
IN MY COMMUNITY I KNOW GUNS ARE
ACTUALLY TURNED IN IN A WIDE
VARIETY OF GUNS THINGS THAT ARE
CLEARLY BROKE AND THINGS THAT
LOOK LIKE NORMAL YOU KNOW. AT A
HANDGUN AND A HOUSE THAT
PROBABLY JUST IT'S BEEN SITTING
THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS.
THINGS THAT A MOTHER FINDS THAT
THERE MAY BE THEIR SON HAD AND
THEY DON'T WANNA GET THEIR SON
IN TROUBLE. OR DAUGHTER ON THAT
THEY FOUND IN THE CLOSET THERE'S
NO OTHER WAY TO GET RID OF THIS
KIND LEGALLY SO I'M GONNA I'M
I'M GONNA COME DOWN AND SAY IF
WE'RE TAKING GUNS OFF THE STREET
I'M FOR. I'M FOR IT I'M FOR
TAKING GUNS OUT OF SOMEBODY'S
HOUSE THAT DOESN'T USE IT NO KID
FINDS IT BLOWS HIS BRAINS OUT
ONE KID IF WE SAY ONE KID I'M
FOR ITS GOOD.
BUT IF WE'RE GONNA DO THAT.
AND ESPECIALLY BECAUSE I READ A
STUDY.
OUT OF MY MISERY THE UNIVERSITY
MISSOURI.
WHERE PROFESSOR WENT TO A ST
LOUIS BY BACK AND THEY WERE
GIVING CASH ABOUT ONE AND WE'LL
DEAL WITH THAT LATER?
BUT THIS IS JUST ABOUT THE THAT.
THE GIFTCARDS BUT AT THAT ONE HE
INTERVIEWED PEOPLE AND ASK WHAT
THEY WERE GOING TO DO WITH THEIR
CASH IN A NUMBER OF THOSE FOLKS
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BUY A NEW.
PAM.
SO AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
PROBLEM AND SOMETHING THAT WE
SHOULD ADDRESS BUT WHAT IT WAS
SO OBVIOUS WALMART IS THE
LARGEST RETAILER ITEM IN GUNS IN
THE NATION. THEY DO SELL
AMMUNITION IN CALIFORNIA THAT
JUST DOESN'T MAKE SENSE THAT OUR
TAXPAYER DOLLARS WOULD ENCOURAGE
SOMEBODY TO GO TO A RETAILER
THAT SELLS COMES IN AND OR
AMMUNITION AND SO THAT'S. THE
NARROW FOCUS OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMIC.
YOU MAY CLOSE I JUST WANNA CLOSE
BY SAYING I RESPECTFULLY
DISAGREE WITH THE OPPONENT WHO
SUGGESTS I GUESS THAT OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT SHOULD HAVE GUNS
UMPS OUT WITHOUT THAT. I DON'T
THINK I'LL BE OFFERING UP THAT
BILL DESPITE WHAT TO GET GUNS
OFF THE STREET. RESPECTFULLY ASK
WHEN I ABOUT.
AND I AND I WON. IT LOOK I I WE
HAVE A BUY. BACK PROGRAM IN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND IN MY DISTRICT. AT THE
COLISEUM WITH A HAVE A BUY BACK
PROGRAM THE LINE GOES AROUND THE
CORNER.
IN FAT THEY RUN OUT OF GIFT
CARDS AND MONEY.
IF WE COULD BUY BACK ALL.
THE GUNS WHICH WE CAN'T BECAUSE
WE CAN'T AFFORD IT COULD WE
DON'T MAKE A PROFIT.
FROM BUYING THESE GUNS BACK IF
WE COULD BUY THEM BACK.
I IS A MEMBER OF THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE PUBLIC SAFETY.
I PROBABLY WOULD BE ENCOURAGING
THAT WE BUY MORE GUNS BACK
BECAUSE I THINK THE MORE GUNS
YOU TAKE OFF THE STREET. THAT
COULD BE HARMFUL TO ANYONE
WHETHER SUICIDE OR THE
COMMISSION OF A CRIME OR
ANYTHING DO WE NEED TO DO THAT.
ARM I WISH THE GOVERNMENT COULD
MAKE A PROFIT OFF OF BUYING BACK
THESE THESE WEAPONS.
ON THE OTHER THING IS THAT WHAT
MR DELUDE BROUGHT UP IT WOULD I
I BELIEVE THEY DO CHECK THE
SERIAL NUMBER BUT I'LL DOUBLE
CHECK. IF THEY DON'T THEN IT
SHOULD BE ADDED TO THE BUY BACK
PROGRAM AND. AND AND IF I HAVE
TO COME UP WITH SOME LEGISLATION
TO DO THAT THEN WE SHOULD. KNOW
COLLECTED THEY HAVE SOME KIND OF
WAY OF KNOWING WHERE THE GUNS
CAME FROM WHEN THEY BUY THEM
BACK BUT GET OUT I'LL DOUBLE
CHECK. COULD NOT CERTAIN I JUST
KNOW IN MY DISTRICT. THEY RAN
OUT OF MONEY RIGHT BY BACK GUNS.
FROM PEOPLE IN MY AT SOUTH LOS
ANGELES IS A CASE YOU DON'T KNOW
MY DISTRICT IF AND SEWER. OF THE
CHAIRS RECOMMENDED AYE VOTE.
IS THERE A MOTION.
THEIR SECOND.
SECOND.
I AB NINETEEN NO THREE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
JONES SAWYER AYE AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE LACKEY.
I CAN NOT VOTING CARDIO.
CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISTER LACKEY.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE
RIGHT THERE. PERFECT YEAH.
LAKE ON NEXT YEAR.
YOU GO FIRST WHO.
AND THEN THE MIKE RGS YEAH RIGHT
AND THEN. CHAU CASSIDY.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN ALRIGHT
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO PRESENT A BE EIGHTEEN SIXTY
FIVE MOVE THE BELL.
RUN A GOOD START.
THIS LEGISLATION BUILDS UPON
EXISTING LAW.
THAT WAS APPROVED BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
WHICH MADE IT A CRIME FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL OR THEIR DOG TO
ATTACK A GUIDE.
SIGNAL OR SERVICE DOGS WELL IT'S
ACTIVELY PROVIDING SERVICE TO
CHANDLER.
UNFORTUNATELY CURRENT LAW FAILS
TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
THAT THE IMPORTANCE OF THESE
SERVICE DOGS EXTEND BEYOND
MOMENTS WHEN A DOG IS ACTIVELY
GUIDING ITS HANDLER.
THE VALUE AND SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE DOG DOES NOT DIMINISH SIMPLY
BECAUSE A HANDLER DECIDES TO
ALLOW THE ANIMAL TO RELAX.
WHILE WAITING FOR A BUS OR
SITTING AT THE PARK.
AB AGED SIXTY FIVE WILL REMOVE
THE REQUIREMENT TO THE DOG BE
PERFORMING ITS DUTIES AT THE
TIME. OF BEING ATTACKED FOR IT
TO BE A CRIME.
ADDITIONALLY CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
DOG OWNERS TO BECOME FIXATED
THROUGH THE VICTIMS COMPENSATION
FUND FOR VETERINARY BILLS
OR THE COST OF REPLACING THE
DOG.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE WILL ALSO
ENABLE THEM TO COLLECT ON
MEDICAL EXPENSES INCURRED AND.
LOST INCOME RESULTING FROM THE
TIME SPENT WITHOUT THE SERVICES
OF THE DOG.
AND NOW TURN IT OVER TURNED I'M
SORRY TURN TIME OVER TO OF THE
SPONSORS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR THE
BLIND.
AND THE NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
THE BLIND CALIFORNIA.
HI I THINK YOU COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND MISTER CHAIR.
MY NAME IS SHANNON DEL AND I
REPRESENT NATIONAL FEDERATION OF
THE BLIND CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. I AM HAVE A THIS MY
SECOND GUIDE DOG AND. MY FIRST
GUIDE WAS A TALK TO COUPLE OF
TIMES AND. FIRST I WANT TO
ADDRESS AND PENAL CODE FIVE
NINETY SEVEN FIVE NINETY SEVEN
POINT ONE WHICH WAS BROUGHT UP
IN OPPOSITION LETTER.
THOSE CODES DO NOT SPECIFICALLY
SPEAK TO THAT.
ISSUE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
THEY SPEAK TO MALICIOUS TORTURE
ARM TREATMENT. FOR NEGLECT OF
ANIMALS IN. GENERAL.
.
THE EXISTING LAW THAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING.
ADDING PROTECTION.
THAT WORRIED EGGS EXISTING LAW
THAT WHERE.
DISCUSSING MAKING CHANGES TO
SPECIFICALLY PROTECTS.
GUIDE SERVICE AND SIGNAL DOGS
WHO ARE ATTACKED BY THESE.
A DOG THAT SOMEONE OWNS OUR
HARBORS.
AND DO WE WANT TO ADD THE
PROTECTIONS TO THE DOGS IN
TRAINING AS WELL AS DOGS WHO
ARE.
CURRENTLY WORKING BUT WHOSE HOME
WHO ARE OUT OF HARNESS WHO ARE
NOT CONSIDERED TO BE AND
PERFORMANCE OF THEIR DUTIES WHEN
THEY'RE ATTACKED THEM. EVERY DAY
I GO TO WORK AND TAKE MY DOG AND
PART OF THE IMPORTANCE OF TAKING
MY DOG OUT OF HARNESS TO RELIEVE
IT. IN PUBLIC BECAUSE OF WHERE I
WORK I HAVE TO RELIEVE IN THE
PUBLIC AND TAKE MY DOG OUT OF
HARNESS EVERYDAY TO DO THAT. AND
BECAUSE IT'S IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE DOG TO KNOW THAT THIS IS A
TIME TO YOU DON'T GO TO THE
BATHROOM IN HARNESS YOU ONLY GO
TO THE BATHROOM WHEN YOU'RE OUT
OF HARNESS.
AND. SO THAT'S SOMETHING THE
SCHOOLS TEACH US ALL IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT SO BY DEFINITIONS ARE
DOGS WILL BE OUT OF HARNESSES
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY CAN EASILY
BE ATTACKED AND I HAVE HAD MY
DOGS ATTACKED.
UP NGUYEN RELIEVE PAIN BY DOGS
LOOSE AND PUBLIC SO I'M.
THIS BILL IS IS VERY IMPORTANT
PROTECTING US ON.
AND DOGS WHO ARE CURRENTLY IN
TRAINING PARA EXPENSIVE THEY
COSTS UPWARDS FROM SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH DOG.
AND SPAY.
.
THERE OFTEN WHEN YOU'RE ATTACKED
THE DOGS GO OUT OF SERVICE THERE
NO LONGER THEY'RE TRAUMATIZED IT
CAN NO LONGER CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. THE WIND MY LAST DOG WAS ON
FINALLY ATTACK SHE JUST STOPPED
WE STOPPED WORKING HER BECAUSE
SHE. WAS FEARFUL OF DOGS
WHENEVER I COLOR OF PARK. OR.
WHEN.
WHENEVER THERE WAS ANOTHER DOG
SHE WOULD JUST BEGIN INTO SHE
SHE COULDN'T FOCUS ON GUIDING ME
SHE WOULD JUST.
STOP AND START LOOKING AROUND
FOR THE OTHER TODD. AND AND I
WAS HORRIFIED TO SO IT'S.
TURNOUT IT YOU DON'T IT'S VERY
HARD TO MOVE FORWARD FROM.
THANK YOU PLAY EVERY SUPPORT
THIS BILL THINK IT.
THANK YOU.
SKIS.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MARGIE
DONOVAN AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK.
MISTER CHAIR FOR BRINGING THIS
PSALM BILL FORWARD AND CERTAINLY
MR LACKEY FOR CARING THE BILL
AND OUR TO SCHOOL SPONSORS TO
THE BILL.
I'VE WORKED WITH GUIDE DOGS FOR
THIRTY SIX YEARS NOW.
I'VE BEEN ATTACKED TWICE
BUT LET ME BACK UP. THIS
ASSISTANT SHOW.
THE MOST GUIDE DOG SITTER TACT
IS IN WITHIN THREE BLOCKS OF
THEIR HOMES.
BOTH ATTACKS IN MY DOG'S CASE
HAPPENED.
ONE HAPPENED IN MY GARAGE AFTER
I BELIEVE MY DOG THE NEIGHBOR'S
DOG RAN AND CHASED HIM INTO THE
YARD BUT HIS TAIL.
AND THE TWO AND A HALF MONTHS
LATER OF GOING TO THE VET EVERY
SINGLE DAY WE SAVED HIS TAIL AND
THEN ONE WORK A DOG WITHOUT A
TAIL.
.
BUT THAT WAS A REAL RISK DURING
THAT BEARD A TIME I CAN SAY
THANK GOD I'M ON RETIRED.
THERE'S NO WAY I WOULD'VE BEEN
ABLE TO TAKE MY DOG TO WORK AND
TO GO THE VET EVERY DAY. AND HE
WAS BLEEDING MY HOUSE ECLECTIC
CRIMES.
CRIMES UNKNOWN AND AND.
THE SECOND ATTACK AYE
EXPERIENCES ALSO WATCHING WITH
MY SIGNIFICANT OTHER WITH MY DOG
OUT OF HARNESS BUT HEALING.
AND A NEIGHBOR'S DOG CAME OUT
AND TRY TO ATTACK BUT MY
SIGNIFICANT OTHER GOT BETWEEN US
SO MY DOG WAS NOT ATTACKED THAT
TIME.
THAT BEING SAID WE KNOW THERE'S
A LOT OF ANIMALS OUT THERE IN
PUBLIC LOT OF DOGS ON LOT A FAKE
SERVICE ANIMALS OUT THERE
PUBLIC.
THEIR FIRST PUTTING OUR DOGS IN
A WAY A LOT MORE DANGER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS.
THE FACT THAT THIS BILL WAS
BROUGHT FORTH I BELIEVE TWO
YEARS AGO.
HI.
AS A. B. EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR.
AND THE GOVERNOR VETOED THE BILL
BECAUSE THE ACLU WAS OPPOSED TO
A PARTICULAR SECTION OF THE
BILL.
WE HAVE REMOVED THAT SECTION
FROM THE BILL IN HOPES THAT THE
ACLU WALL NOW NOT OPPOSE OUR
BILL.
.
AS MR LACKEY IS PROBABLY AWARE
THEY RECEIVED THE PHONE CALL BUT
NOT A LETTER FROM THE ACLU
OPPOSING THIS BILL.
THE ORGANIZATION.
.
COMING SOON.
THE ORGANIZATION OF PUBLIC
DEFENDERS HAS WRITTEN A LETTER
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL.
AND.
SHANNON I HAVE BEEN TRYING ALL
LAST WEEK IMPARTED YESTERDAY TO
TRY TO MEET WITH THEM.
AND DID A SCHEDULE CONFLICTS
THAT HAS NOT TAKEN PLACE HOWEVER
I WAS TOLD BY NICK HIMSELF THAT
HE WOULD NOT OPPOSE IT TODAY. IN
HEARINGS.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO SAY.
THAT.
ANY SB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE
PAVLEY WAS PASSED TWO YEARS AGO.
AND THAT WILLOWS TO ALLOW THOSE
OF US WITH DOGS FROM OTHER
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
WATCHER THERE'S FOURTEEN IN THE
STATE THREE IN CALIFORNIA.
.
THAT BILL ALLOWED US TO GET
FOLLOW UP HERE.
IF SOMETHING HAPPENED HER DOG.
AND OUR TRIP HOME AND AWAY
TRAINING LIKE LAST TIME I
TRAINED I HAD MOVED TO THIS AREA
OUTSIDE THEIR HOME AWAY WHICH
MEANS A STRUCTURE CAME HOME WITH
ME FOR A WEEK. AND I SEE THIS
BILL ACTUALLY ADDING ON TO THAT
AND SUPPORTING OUR EFFORTS TO
WORK FREELY AND INDEPENDENTLY.
OWNED BUSINESSES AND ON THE
STREETS
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ALSO HAVE A NUMBER OF DOGS IT
NEEDLESSLY TO SAY THEY COME INTO
THE STATE FOR A VISIT.
IN CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO ASK
FOR A YES VOTE ON THIS BILL.
TO SUPPORT OUR FREEDOM OUR
INDEPENDENT AND MY FINAL WORDS
IS WE WOULD IF THIS OF THIS BILL
IF PASSED WOULD ACTUALLY BRING.
THE REQUIREMENT ABOUT EQUIPMENT.
ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH THE EIGHTY
EIGHT THE ADA GOES ON THE
TRAINING OF THE DOG NAFI
EQUIPMENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELL THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YES MY
NAME IS PATTY JOHNSON I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBER. I
HAVE A DOG THIS IS MY SIXTH AUG
EXCITEMENT NINE YEARS SHE'S BEEN
ATTACKED WHILE WE LEAVING.
SEVEN DIFFERENT TIMES AND I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
UP TO OUR KNEES YOU YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION.
NAME AND ORGANIZATION.
JEFF TOMGRAM AFFAIRS CHAIR
CALIFORNIA COUNSEL BLIND CHAIR
JONES SAWYER AND MEMBERS OF
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
.
I HAVE WHERE.
ALL.
NOT.
RIGHT FROM TEHACHAPI I'M A
MEMBER THE GOLDEN STATE GUIDE
DOG HANDLERS.
I'VE HAD THREE GUIDE DOGS TWO
OF THEM HAVE BEEN ATTACKED ONE
WAS ATTACKED OUT OF HARNESS ON
AN AMTRAK TRAIN. WHILE WE WERE
TRAVELING FROM.
OREGON TO CALIFORNIA.
AND MY OTHER ONE OF MY OTHER DOG
WAS ATTACKED.
WHILE WORKING. AND HAD TO BE
RETIRED.
THANK YOU I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
FOR EIGHTEEN.
A FIVE THANK YOU.
NAME AN ORGANIZATION PLEASE.
I GUESS
DENNIS ROSS RACH OTHER ELECTED
MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
RIVER CITY CHAPTER OF THE
NATIONAL FEDERATION OF THE
BLIND.
MOON.
ONE OF MY FRIENDS IN THE LOCAL
CHAPTER WAS ATTACKED ON LIGHT
RAIL I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT.
FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU MAKE YOU.
DEBORAH ROTH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA VERY STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DOCTOR THOMAS LEPORELLO.
EIGHTY A.
THE.
IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
OTHER.
IT THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YOU HAVE ANY
COMMENTS QUESTIONS
CONCERNED.
SELECT EMAIL CLOSE.
YEAH I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE SO THAT
THIS PART OF OUR. POPULATION AND
THEIR COMPANIONS TO FEEL FULLY
PROTECTED.
THANK YOU.
.
SO WITH THAT CHAIR.
IT'S GOING TO RECOMMEND THIS.
ARM MY MY BROTHER'S BEEN
VISUALLY IMPAIRED SINCE HE WAS
FOR FROM BIRTH.
AND HE.
COULDN'T BRING HIS
SERVICE DOG GUYS GO TO SCHOOL
THE DC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
AT A REFUSE TO ALLOW HIM TO
BRING IT TO SCHOOL.
.
BEING A JONES SAWYER THE
PROTESTS AND SAT FRONT PORCH WAS
OFFICE UNTIL.
HE FORCED THEM TO ALLOW ME TO
BRING HIS SERVICE DOG.
BOB.
I THINK RIGHT AFTER THAT DC
SCHOOL SYSTEM.
CHANGED THEIR THEIR DARED
DISABLED HANDICAP POLICIES FREE
ENTIRE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
OF THE WHAT THE CASSIE WAS HIS
DOG
HIS GUIDE DOG.
.
DOCTOR FREDRIC CLIFFORD JONES.
WHO IS A VICE PRINCIPAL AND THE
DC SCHOOL SYSTEM HE WOULD BE
SUPERINTENDENT?
BUT YOU KNOW HE ADVOCATES FOR
FOR THE HANDICAPPED EVERY DAY HE
GOES TO WORK IN THE DC SCHOOL
SYSTEM.
AND BASS IS A PAIN THE* BUT
YOU KNOW IT BE SUPERINTENDENT
SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW.
IF WE WAS LITTLE MORE.
AMANDA AMENABLE TO BE A
POLITICAL BUT HE'S NOT. AND HE'S
A STRONG ADVOCATE OF FREE A
COMMUNITY.
AND I ASKED HIM ABOUT THIS
AND HE WAS.
.
WHO'S VERY FORMATIVE ANY HELPED
WITH HELPING TO CRAFT THIS I'M
GLAD YOU. YOU WORKED IT OUT WITH
THE ACLU.
DEATHLY GOING TO RECOMMEND THAT
WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS TIME
AND I'M HAPPY THAT MISTER LACKEY
BROAD FOR. SUCH AS RECOMMENDED
AYE VOTE.
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE KALLIO.
KALLIO AYE GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE QUIRK.
QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU THANK
YOU
.
AMERICAN
AYE FOOTPATH YOU HAVE.
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU
MISTER LACKEY. ARE MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS FIRST I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE.
AND MY STAFF.
FOR THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THIS
BILL.
I'M PER COMMITTEE SHOULD.
PER COMMITTEE. CAMP SUGGESTIONS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WILL BE
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS BEING
DISTRIBUTED TO MEMBERS NOW.
TO ALIGN TO BUILD WITH CURRENT
LAW. I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT A.
B. NINETEEN FORTY WHICH WILL
ALLOW PAROLEES THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EARN. RE AND TO GRAYSON
CREDITS TO REDUCE THE TERM OF
HIS OR HER PAROLE.
WHILE INCARCERATED FOLK'S HAVE
ACCESS TO EDUCATIONAL VOCATIONAL
PROGRAMS WHICH UPON COMPLETION
CAN BE REDEEMED FOR TIME CREDIT
OR SHORTENING A SENTENCE.
WHEREAS PRO REQUIREMENTS ARE
CURRENTLY TIME BASED AND NOT
GOAL ORIENTED AB NINETEEN FORTY
WILL INCENTIVIZE INDIVIDUALS TO
COMPLETE THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS.
THE BOOK THE BILL LAYS OUT.
PACIFIC ON HOW MUCH TIME WE
PROBABLY WILL EARN EACH YEAR FOR
COMPLETING AN EDUCATIONAL DEGREE
COLLEGE COURSE. COMMUNITY
SERVICE HOURS GOOD BEHAVIOR OR
SOME OF THE PEWS TREATMENT NOT
MANDATED BY THE COURT. A. B.
NINETEEN FORTY WILL ALSO HELP
REDUCED CASELOAD FOR THE ALREADY
OVERBURDENED PAROLE AGENTS
AFFORDING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
TO FOCUS ON PAROLEES THAT NEED
EXTRA ATTENTION ASSISTANCE AND
GUIDANCE Y. ALONE DOES ON
EDUCATIONAL PATH. TO CONTINUE
DRIVING AB NINETEEN FORTIES A
MIDDLE GROUND APPROACH MODEL BY
THE SUCCESS OF OTHER MORE
CONSERVATIVE STATES WITH ME
TODAY. IS DAVID MUHAMMAD EJECTED
DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM AND MICHAEL MENDOZA
POLICY ASSOCIATE WOULD CUT
FORTY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
IT WOULD JUST BY.
GOOD MORNING.
TO
CHAIRMAN JONES SAWYER AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS DAVID MUHAMMAD OF
EXECUTIVE RECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
INSTITUTE FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM I'M ALSO A FORMER
CHRISTIAN MINISTRY HER IN A NEW
YORK CITY WASHINGTON DC IN
HEARING CALIFORNIA. WHERE WAS
THE CHIEF OPERATION OFFICER OF
ALAMEDA COUNTY?
I JUST BY TODAY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN FORTY A
BILL THAT WOULD IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES OF PEOPLE ON PAROLE.
EASE THE BURDEN OF OVERWORK
PAROLE AGENTS AND INCREASE
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB NINETEEN FORTY WILL
INCENTIVIZE PAROLEES TO ACHIEVE
SUCCESS
BY PROVIDING SIGNIFICANT
EDUCATIONAL CREDITS.
OFFER EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENTS
AS WELL AS CREDITS FOR
COMPLETING TREATMENT PROGRAMS
AND VOLUNTEER SERVICE.
THIS BILL WILL ENCOURAGE PEARL
LISA FOCUSED ON THEIR OWN
DEVELOPMENT TREATMENT. AND
REFRAIN FROM CRIMINAL ACTIVITY.
MY PASSING AB NINETEEN FORTY
CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN THIRTY SIX
OTHER STATES IN PROVIDING GOOD
TIME CREDITS FOR PAROLEES WHO
COMPLY WITH CONDITIONS OF THEIR
SUPERVISION. AND STATE FREE FROM
CRIME.
BUT CALIFORNIA WILL BECOME A
LEADER BY TAKING A STEP FURTHER
AND INCENTIVIZING ACHIEVEMENT.
THE EMPHASIS ON EDUCATION IN
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL AND
EVIDENCE BASED AID TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN RAND CORPORATION STUDY
REVEALED THAT PEOPLE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM WHO
COMPLETE IN EDUCATION PROGRAM.
WERE FORTY THREE PERCENT LESS
LIKELY TO BE SENT BACK TO PRISON
THAN THOSE WHO DID NOT.
PEARL THE TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
THESE INCENTIVES WILL BE
INHERENTLY LESS AT RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY. TO BEGIN WITH.
AND THEY WILL ALSO REDUCE THEIR
RISK AS THEY EARN COLLEGE
CREDITS INCOMPLETE TREATMENT
PROGRAMS.
AS LOWER RISK PAROLEES EARNED
TIME OFF ROLE.
THIS WILL ALLOW PAROLE AGENTS TO
FOCUS THEIR LIMITED TIME AND
RESOURCES ON THE SMALL NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO POSE A GREATER RISK
TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
NUMEROUS STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
CORRECTIONAL SUPERVISION OF
LOWER RISK PEOPLE IS AN
EFFECTIVE. A WASTE OF RESOURCES
AND ACTUALLY CAUSES WORSE
OUTCOMES.
ONE STUDY BY THE PEW CENTER ON
THE STATE'S DETERMINE THAT AFTER
FIFTEEN MONTHS OF CORRECTIONAL
SUPERVISION WITHOUT A VIOLATION
OR NEW OFFENSE THE LIKELIHOOD
THAT A PEARL WHO COMMITTED NEW
CRIMES SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASES.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS EIGHTEEN
STATES ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
ENACTED EARNED COMPLIANCE
CREDITS WITH PROBATION AS A
PAROLE THESE WHO CAN EARN THIRTY
DAYS OFF OF THEIR SUPERVISION
TIME FOR EVERY THIRTY DAYS OFF
OF FOR NO VIOLATIONS OF NEW
OFFENSES.
DETAILED STUDIES IN TWO OF THOSE
STATES MISSOURI AND ARIZONA.
SHOW THAT THE NEW LAWS WERE
ACHIEVING THEIR INTENDED IMPACT
PEARL AGENTS CASE HOLES WERE
SMALLER CORRECTIONAL SPENDING
WAS REDUCED AND THE RECIDIVISM
RATE OF THE PEOPLE WHO EARNED
EARLY RELEASE DECLINED.
CALIFORNIA HAS EVEN IMPLEMENTED
A VERSION OF THIS
UNDER AB ONE ON NINE PEOPLE
RELEASED FROM PRISON ON POST
RELEASE COMMITTEE SUPERVISION
WHO WOULD HAVE BEEN ON PAROLE
BUT ARE NOW UNDER PROBATION.
COULD HAVE THEIR THREE YEAR
SUPERVISION TERMINATED AFTER
JUST SIX MONTHS
AND MUST HAVE THEIR SUPERVISION
TERMINATED AFTER ONE YEAR IF
THERE ARE NO VIOLATIONS OF NEW
ARRESTS.
AND NOW CALIFORNIA CAN IMPROVE
UPON THIS EFFECTIVE PRACTICE AND
INCENTIVIZE PAROLEES NOT ONLY TO
REFRAIN FROM CRIME BUT TO
ACHIEVE SUCCESS.
I STRONGLY URGE THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS AB
NINETEEN FORTY THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR ALLOWING ME THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SLIDE SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN
FORTY AS WELL.
AT THE AGE OF FIFTEEN ENTRANCE
THAT THE ALL PRISON SYSTEMS
SERVE CLOSE TO EIGHTEEN YEARS.
AND IT BECAME REALLY REAL FOR ME
WHEN I EARNED A RELEASE STATES
THAT I WAS COMING HOME.
I WAS WELL AWARE OF THE
CHALLENGES I WAS GOING TO FACE.
AND ACTUALLY FACING THOSE
CHALLENGES I DIDN'T KNOW TO BE
QUITE DIFFICULT BUT THEY HAVE
BEEN.
I PAROLED CLOSE TO OVER THREE
HUNDRED MILES AWAY FOR MY FAMILY
AND ALL MY SUPPORT SYSTEM
BECAUSE I HAD TO.
TO START A NEW LIFE TO START
OVER.
TO THIS DAY I CAN VISIT MY
FAMILY BECAUSE I CAN'T TRAVEL
OUTSIDE OF FIFTY MILES.
REST ASSURED I HAVE PERMISSION
TO BE HERE TODAY.
EVEN ALMOST SEVENTY MILES AWAY
FROM HOME FOR ME.
SO YES I HAVE A CHILD PASSED TO
BE HERE.
THOSE BARRIERS AND OTHERS MAKE
IT EVEN MORE DIFFICULT TO
SUCCESSFULLY DISCHARGE PAROLE.
AT TIMES YOU HAVE TO DECIDE
WHETHER YOU WANT TO WORK FULL
TIME OR TRY TO ADVANCE TO
EDUCATIONAL DEGREE BY GOING BACK
TO SCHOOL.
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO DO BOTH.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW SOMEBODY
LIKE MYSELF TO EARN EARLIER
DISCHARGE.
IT'LL GIVE ME THAT SENSE OF
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT I HAVE DONE
THIS ON MY OWN.
IT WILL GIVE YOU A GOAL TO REACH
TOWARDS THIS WILL PROVIDE A A
GOAL ORIENTED APPROACH ON PAROLE
WHERE PEOPLE CAN.
EARNED THAT THIS SHOW YOU SAY
THIS IS WHAT I ACCOMPLISHED.
AND THAT'S IS OF A CONSUMMATE
ACCOMPLISHMENT GOES A LONG WAY
EVEN AFTER THAT.
I TRULY BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL.
ALTHOUGH MY DISCHARGE A PRO IS
NOT FOR CERTAIN BECAUSE I AM ON
LIFETIME PAROLE.
THIS BILL BECOMES A GOAL THAT
CAN REACH FOR A TAKE CHARGE OF
AND WORK HARDER TOWARDS.
THESE INCENTIVES AND REWARDS
GIVE SUBSTANCE TO THE REASONS I
SHOULD BE THIS CHARGE.
AND PROVIDE A MORE MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCE FOR MYSELF AND
OTHERS.
SO I STRONGLY URGE FOR YOUR
SUPPORT ON THIS BILL AND THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE TIME THAT
YOU ARE GIVING US.
SORRY.
YEAH ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHAU HANDLE OUT.
PAYMENT.
NAMING ORGANIZATIONALLY PLEASE
BUT WE'RE GONNA SOURCE FOR
FREEDOM OF FOR HIS BILL.
IF YOU.
BUT ON THE GO ANY DOES ONE SALAS
ON BEHALF PLACER CALIFORNIA
CENTER FOR AGASSI IN POLICY
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RAYMOND GARCIA FROM
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION.
AND I'M ONE HUNDRED PERCENT
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CAN MENDOZA I'M THE
POLICY COORDINATOR IDENTIFIES
CITIZEN COALITION AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
I AM FRENCH CHOSE THE BELL A
RECENTLY RELEASED PRISONER AND
I'M FULL SUPPORTED THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS WILLIE WILSON.
AMONG.
BEEN RELEASED.
FOR MONTHS NOW SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
YEAR SENTENCE.
I LIKE TO SPEAK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HIS BILL. HIGH COULD HELP.
INTERRUPT YOU CERTAINLY
SEARCHES NEWMAN ORGANIZATION
PLANTS OUT I'M SORRY.
I'M FOR SUPPORTERS BILL THANK
YOU.
MY NAME'S.
MY NAME IS TAMMY LAND I AM A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED STUDENT AT
SACRAMENTO STATE. I AM WITH
PROJECT REBOUND AND THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SHANIQUA LIAM'S I'M
FORMALLY INCARCERATE I'M
CURRENTLY ON PAROLE I WAS
RELEASED NOVEMBER EIGHTH TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN I AM
CURRENTLY PURSUING MY MASTERS
DEGREE AND HOPE TO GO TO LAW
SCHOOL IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN.
I AM AND HOW TO PERCENT SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. AQ.
MY NAME IS SERIOUSLY BIRDS AND I
AM A MEMBER A ARE SEE I WORK
WITH CUT FIFTY ALSO I AM IN ONE
HUNDRED PERCENT SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT AFFECTS ME AS
WELL. LIKE YOU.
RYAN LOW DIRECTOR OF OPERATIONS
COMMUTE TRANSITIONS INITIATIVE
AYE SPORTS MEASURE.
YOU.
MY NAME'S HANDLED THESE I'M A
MEMBER OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND THE COFOUNDER OF
SOFTWARE SOME RECOVERY
NATIONALLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS ISAAC MADISON I'M A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED MEN AND
I'M A MEMBER THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MY NAME'S TRAVIS BLAIR WHAT THEY
ARE SEEING ON THE CURRENT
PAROLEES I'M STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
GET.
HI MY NAME IS CHRISTINA BURMAN
DOES I'M A PART OF FEEL FAMILIES
UNITED TO AND LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
YOU.
JASON BILL REGIONAL DIRECTOR
PROJECT REBOUND FORM
INCARCERATED PERSON AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL THANK.
SENATE TOMSKY ALSO HERE WITH
PROJECT REBOUND SAN FRANCISCO
STATE FARM INCARCERATED IN
STRONGLY IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THE QUEUE.
NICOLE OPENSHAW WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I'M A
STUDENT I'M A SURVIVOR OF
VIOLENT CRIME AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. YOU.
ANDREW GRAINGER WHEN DIRECTOR
PRIVATE REBOUND CHECK WILL STATE
UNDERGROUND SCHOLARS UCLA
JUSTICE WORKGROUP PARISHES IN
COALITION THAT STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOE RONALD FROMM I'M
A MEMBER OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND I WERE FOR THE LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE.
AND A STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS JAMES MACKEY CURRENT
BROLY.
MEMBER OF ANTI SERVICE
RECIDIVISM COALITION CURRENT
STUDENT YOU'LL P. AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THAT BILL.
WELL I UP WINDOWS.
HEY I'M CAN DO EXAMS THEN I'M
AN ACTOR AND ACTIVIST.
LOVE YOU AND.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I'M HERE WITH. CUT FIFTY
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSE GONZALEZ
THE INSIDE COORDINATOR AT THE
ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION AN
INTERN AT WARNER BROTHERS.
A SENIOR AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY LOS ANGELES
ABOUT TO EARN MY BACHELORS
DEGREE IN PSYCHOLOGY ANIMAL
PEARL AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
LISA SMALL I AM REPRESENTING LOS
ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ROBERT CORONA NAM
PART OF ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION AND AND I SUPPORTED
BILL WITH ALL MY HEART AND SO.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS SUMMIT COME OUT THAT
I AM A FORMERLY INCARCERATED
WOMAN.
A MAMMA. AND IS NOW THE PRISON
REENTRY DIRECTOR AT THE YOUNG
WOMEN'S FREEDOM CENTER IN SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL LIKE.
HI MY NAME IS NEERAJ KUMAR I'M
AN ATTORNEY AND A LEGAL FELLOW
AT WRITTEN REBOUND REENTRY
ADVOCATES STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. LIKE YOU.
PINE MY NEIGHBORS LAPEL BAYLOR
I'M WITH THEY ARE SEE I'M A
FORMERLY INCARCERATED WOMAN I'M
ALSO OF VIETNAM OF MIDDLE
AIRFORCE VETERAN. ARM I AND I'M
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR FREEDOM
FOR YOUTH AND SEND A PROPER.
AND I SIX STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL MAKE YOU.
I NICK BROKE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
YOU.
MY NAME IS WORTH EDWARD SOME OF
FORMALLY INCARCERATED HONORED
MEMBER OF ALPHA PHI SIGMA
RETHINK GRADUATE BOUNCERS DEGREE
AT SAC STATE. OF.
WHAT I CURRENTLY WORK FOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION AND I AM
FULLY IN SUPPORT OF ALL THE
POWER THIS BILL HOLES THANK YOU
LIKE YOU?
HIGH AND LOW OF MCLEAN AND I AM
WITH CUT
DE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
SPELL.
LIKE YOU.
HI MY NAME IS JAMIE JAMIE CLARK
I AM REPRESENTING CUT FIFTH
FIFTY AND I FULLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
BUT SHEILA TELE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION TALKS WITH THIS BILL
LIKE YOU.
ALEX GOOD EACH WITH CUT FIFTY
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MORNINGS CHAIR MEMBERS SEAN
OFTEN WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION.
I RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION WHO BAIT
AND SWITCH ADDED REALISM
OPPOSING THE CHAIR TODAY.
UP. WE APPRECIATE INTENT OF THE
BILL CERTAINLY.
TO CREATE SENTENCE FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO REHABILITATE
REINTEGRATE INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND CERTAINLY PROCEED THE
AMENDMENT. I WAS TAKEN TO GET
RID OF THE CREDITS FOR
ESSENTIALLY NOT HAVING YOUR
PAROLE REVOKED.
OR CONCERNS THAT REMAIN.
PRIMARILY THAT ALL OFFENDERS
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR THESE CREDITS
INCLUDE PROMOTERS VIOLENT
OFFENDERS SEX OFFENDERS EVEN
THOSE ON LIFETIME PAROLE.
I THAT'S THAT'S OF CONCERN TO US
THE BILL DOES DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AS WELL AS THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
PROMULGATE REGULATIONS. THAT
COULD THEORETICALLY EXCLUDE
CERTAIN OFFENDERS BUT AS WE'VE
SEEN WITH THE PROPERTY SEVEN
REGULATIONS.
.
THAT EXCLUDE SEX OFFENDERS WE
THINK IT'S IT'S PROBABLY BEST
THAT IF THERE ARE ANY INTENDED
DISQUALIFIER IS THAT THOSE BE
WRITTEN INTO THE BILL.
.
ULTIMATELY THOUGH THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE MOST LIKELY TO BENEFIT FROM
THIS ARE THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHOSE
OFFENSES WERE SO SERIOUS THAT
THEY'VE RECEIVED LENGTHY PAROLE
TALES.
LOW LEVEL OFFENDERS TO THE
EXTENT THAT ANYONE LOW LEVEL.
GOES STATE PRISON AND ENDS UP ON
PAROLE WOULD LIKELY BE OFF PEARL
BEFORE MOST OF THESE CREDITS
COULD BE EARNED.
AND SO WE WE DON'T SEE THE
PUBLIC BENEFIT IN HAVING SERIOUS
AND VIOLENT OFFENDERS
UNSUPERVISED IN THE COMMUNITY
SOONER AS THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE REMAIN OPPOSED.
GOOD MORNING TO SHARE MEMBERS
JOHN BAKER ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
AS WAS JUST MENTIONED WE AGREE
WITH THE INTENT IN THAT THE
PURPOSE BEHIND THIS BILL.
CERTAINLY BELIEVE IN
INCENTIVIZINGNOW THE RE ENTRY
PROCESS.
OUR OPPOSITION IS BASED ON THE
FACT THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH THE DEPARTMENT NOW
ON IT EARNED DISCHARGE POLICY.
THERE ARE SOME INCONSISTENCIES.
BETTER THERE ARE BETWEEN THE
POLICY THAT WE'RE WORKING ON IT
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
AND WE DID HAVE A VERY
PRODUCTIVE MEETING WITH THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL.
AS WELL AS THE SPONSORS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS.
SOME SPACE THERE THERE'S SOME
ROOM THERE FOR US TO WORK.
TO WORK TOGETHER.
.
WE ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE SOME AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN TAKEN SOME VERY SIGNIFICANT
AMENDMENTS HAVE BEEN TAKING.
AND.
AND WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN
WORK THROUGH AND THROUGH THE
REMAINING ISSUES BUT. UNTIL
THAT'S INTO THAT HAPPENS WE WE
REMAIN OPPOSED.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES. I'M SORRY
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU MAKE CLOSER OKAY.
BUT I'M SORRY.
GO AHEAD.
SKYLER.
THANK YOU SO I THINK THERE IS.
YOU KNOW GOOD IDEA.
IN THIS BILL THAT.
.
YOU KNOW EARNING REINTEGRATION
CREDITS.
FOR.
THINGS LIKE THAT GETTING A
DEGREE OR TREATMENT PROGRAMS OR
AYE AYE PROBABLY SOME JOB
TRAINING PROGRAMS OR THERE'S A.
AND IT IN SPACE TO LINK TO
REHABILITATION.
REINTEGRATION RECIDIVISM.
I THINK THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
TO THAT IDEA BUT THEN THIS SEEMS
TO ME TO KIND OF GO OVERBOARD
AND THEN ALLOWING FOR CREDITS TO
BE EARNED FIRST THINGS LIKE YOU
KNOW WHAT WORKING WITH A
GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
ANY FORM OF.
WORKING FOR A NONPROFIT WITHOUT
ANY LIMITATION EVEN VISITING
JAILS SIZE SUN WONDERING HOW IT
IS YOU KIND OF LANDED ON THAT
THE UNIVERSITY YOU HAVE IN THIS
BILL OF QUALIFYING ACTIVE.
YEAH I THINK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION SO.
PART IS BILL IS TO. ENCOURAGE
INDIVIDUALS FOR RANSOM TO
SOCIETY TO VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME
WITH NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS.
SOME OF THINGS THAT I DO IS I
NAM I VOLUNTEER MY TIME WITH
ANTI WAS HIDDEN COALITION. TO GO
BACK INTO PRISONS AND ENCOURAGE
THE MEN AND WOMEN INSIDE TO DO
THE BEST THEY CAN AND AND THIS
IS IT AND PROVIDE WORKSHOPS ON.
WHAT TO EXPECT WHEN THEY DO COME
HOME?
AND I BELIEVE THAT FOR ANY MAN
OR WOMAN TO. BE ABLE TO
VOLUNTEER THEIR TIME AND TO GO
BACK INTO FACILITIES.
TO BE OF SERVICE TO.
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO MAKE THEIR
COMMUNITIES SAFER BY. APPEARING
THESE MEN AND WOMEN TO COME HOME
AND HOW TO COME HOME I THINK
THAT'S.
SOMETHING THAT EVERYBODY ON
PAROLE SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZE TO
DO AND WHAT TO DO.
I THINK IT ENCOURAGES PEOPLE TO
BE MORE PROACTIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES INSTEAD OF RECLUSIVE
FROM THE COMMUNITIES.
MANY TIMES A LOT PEOPLE PRO ARE
DISCOURAGED.
FROM VOLUNTEERING THEIR TIME
MORE WORK EVEN HARDER. TO BE NOW
STANLEY CITIZENS OF SOCIETY AND
ALSO MOST OF THESE.
.
INCENTIVES DO IS TO REALLY
ENCOURAGE MEN AND WOMEN TO BE
MORE PROACTIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND HELP MAKE IT COMMITTEES EVEN
SAFER SO THAT'S WHY IT THE
VOLUNTEER TIME FOR. NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS IS IS IN THIS
BILL.
IT'S A CIVIC IN GAUGE MINT IS
DEVELOPMENTAL AND CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT HAS BEEN FOUND TO
RESEARCH TO BE A PART OF WHICH
REDUCES RECIDIVISM AND SOLD THE
WHOLE PART OF THIS BILL IS TO
INCENTIVIZE ACTIVITY ENGAGEMENT
TREATMENT THAT WOULD REDUCE AND
INSTEAD OF OF RECIDIVISM. AND
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IS A
SIGNIFICANT PART OF IT.
IBM DOESN'T SEEM THAT IF IF YOU
HAVE EVIDENCE TO THAT EFFECT I
MEAN.
YOU KNOW I I AGREE THAT I HAD
TO DO WITH THE FIRST GENTLEMAN
SAID THAT THESE ARE I THINK THAT
WE OUGHT TO ENCOURAGE ME THERE'S
KIND OF AN UNLIMITED. AYE
UNIVERSITY OF GOOD. HUMAN
BEHAVIORS THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY REWARD AND WHAT I
THINK WE NEED TO HONE IN ON IS
THOSE THAT HAVE A DEMONSTRABLE
LINK.
TO REHABILITATION REDUCE
RECIDIVISM AND SO YOU KNOW AND I
COULD SEE.
A FIT BETWEEN ABOUT WHAT THE
EVIDENCE SHOWS REDUCE RECIDIVISM
AND WHAT WE'RE INCENTIVIZE IN
THIS BILL THEN I THINK I CAN GET
AROUND TO SUPPORTING IT BUT I'D
THIS POINT I'M I'M GONNA WAIT TO
SEE HOW IT EVOLVES AND I HOPE
THAT YOU'LL. AYE PLEASE PASS MY
CONCERNS ON THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU.
AND THANK YOU TO THE COALITION
FOR BEING HERE TODAY AND TO THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
COME TO YOUR HOUSE THE PEOPLE'S
HOUSE AND HEARD YOUR STORIES.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT EVIDENCE YOU
ARE THE WALKING EVIDENCE OF WHAT
IT MEANS TO.
LIVE THAT LIFE WANTS TO GO BACK
TO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND REALLY CHANGE THE WAY WE
THINK ABOUT WHO WE ARE
INCARCERATING AS IT HIGHLY
IMPACTS PEOPLE OF COLOR. AND SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR TESTIMONIES AND
COMING TO OUR STATE CAPITOL IN
BEING HERE ONCE AGAIN IN YOUR
HOUSE THE PEOPLE'S.
I'M ET I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND OF. A FIRST DATE
THAT THE CHAIR HAD CONCERNED
ABOUT.
DOES THE.
WHAT WE WERE DOING WAS OVER
REACHING ARE GOING TOO FAR AND I
THINK?
DEE DEE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS
TOOK SOME SOME AMENDMENTS DEBT
THAT NARROWED IT SO THAT WE WE.
LEAST CHAIR HAS CONFIDENCE IN
SUPPORTING MOVING ON WITH THIS
THAT THE SECOND PART MISTER
LACKEY NINE.
.
TO KILEY AND I ARE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS AND TWO
OF US ARE LOOKING AT HOW THE.
GET A SENSE AN AUDIT OR A SENSE
OF DUTY WORK DON'T WORK AND.
AND I THINK I'VE TALKED TO
CCPOA ABOUT THAT SO THE ADAM.
IF YOU'RE CONCERNED DUTIES
PROGRAM DEFTLY WORKED IT.
HAVING SOMEONE GOING TO LOVE
VOLUNTEERING DOES IT ACTUALLY
WORK IN AND GET SOME DATA.
SO THAT WE CAN WE CAN SHOW HOW
EFFECTIVE THEY ARE ON THE MOVE
FORWARD SO. A. THE THIRD THING I
IN THE FINAL THING I KNOW THE
AUTHOR OF MR MCCARTY.
I TO SPEAK FOR HIM HE'S VERY
WILLING TO WORK WITH BOTH CCPOA
IN AN IN CALIFORNIA DA'S.
TO STRENGTHEN THIS BILL TO MAKE
SURE BECAUSE ONE OF YOU WORK
WITH THEM AS THEY GO WHEN ONE OF
YOU WORK FOR THE COMBINED AARON.
AND WE NEED YOUR HELP IN
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE REHABILITATION PROGRAM
AND SO. ON I RESPECTFULLY ASK OF
FOR THE COMMITTEES AYE VOTE
BECAUSE I I KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVE THE BELL.
CALL FOR THE QUESTION.
ON AB NINETEEN FORTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER AYE AYE JONES SAWYER AYE
LACKEY NO FOR NOW. LACKEY NO
CARILLO. CARILLO AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY NOT VOTING QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU
.
WE ARE DOING.
THAT WAS.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN SEVENTEEN
THIRTY FIVE SANTIAGO.
ITEM NUMBER ONE SEVENTEEN THIRTY
FIVE.
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTEEN THIRTY
SEVEN.
SANTIAGO.
NO ON RECONSIDERATION.
AND RECONSIDERATION AYE ITEM
NUMBER THREE.
SANTIAGO SEVENTEEN FORTY SIX.
I SANTIAGO AYE.
I DINNER FOR WAS PULLED.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE WAS PULLED AT A
NUMBER SIX WAS PULLED.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT A. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY TWO SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE A. B. EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY TWO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
AT A NUMBER TENS ON CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN.
AB NINETEEN OF PRE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TWENTY GONZALEZ
FLETCHER.
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN WITHOUT
CONSENT.
I THE NUMBER FOURTEEN HAS JUST
BEEN DISPENSED WITH. ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN WAS ON CONSENT.
SIXTEEN WAS ON CONSENT ITEMS
SEVENTEEN WITH ON CONSENT.
OKAY I.
BACK.
BOB PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
STANDS ADJOURNED